bonjour à tous suite du projet de loi de
finances pour 2011 et retour à la séance
d'hier soir pendant la nuit les
sénateurs ont examiné les crédits de la
mission logement des crédits en baisse
de 2,6 % en 2011 par rapport à 2010
concrètement vont être affecté l'aide au
logement à la pierre ou encore à la
politique de la ville alors qu'au
contraire les budgets liés à
l'hébergement d'urgence sont en hausse
hier soir plusieurs rapporteurs se sont
montrés assez critique par rapport à ce
budget philippe Dallier pour la
commission des finances a estimé que ce
budget manquait de sincérité budgétaire
que par exemple le gouvernement
sous-estime le coût des unités
hôtelières dans l'hébergement d'urgence
de son côté Thierry Repentin pour la
commission de l'économie trouve que le
gouvernement se désinvestit de la
construction de logements sociaux enfin
la commission des affaires sociales a
trouvé que ce budget manquait d'équité
que par exemple il crée un prê à taux
zéro pour les populations plus aisées
alors que nous sommes en crise tout de
suite donc retour à la séance d'hier
soir très bonne
séance messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le Sénat va examiner les
crédits de la mission ville et logement
et l'article 98 et
99 la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
daller commission des finances pardon
monsieur le
Président Madame la Présidente messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues je vis
d'abord
saluer monsieur le roi et Monsieur
apparu les félicités et pour
l'importante mission qu'ils ont amené au
sein du gouvernement de François Fillon
et leur exprimer tous nos vœux à cette
heure avancée de la soirée je voudrais
monsieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues vous indiquez que nous devrons
impérativement clore cette séance avant
1h30 du matin parce que l'ordre du jour
a prévu des questions orales demain
matin nous avons pu décaler l'horaire de
ces questions de 10h à 10h30 mais nous
ne pourrons pas aller au-delà
d'1h30 il nous reste 170
minutes si je prends le décompte des
temps de parole nous aurons 25 minutes
pour entendre les rapporteurs le
rapporteur spécial et les rapporteurs
pour avis et puis 57 minutes pour la
discussion générale 20 minutes pour les
ministres ça fait 102 minutes ce que
nous n'avions pas prévu et c'est le
dépôt de 26 amendements et trois prises
de parole sur les articles rattachés
objectivement
il me paraît peu probable que nous
puissions clore nos travaux avant 1h30
si tel est le cas malheureusement
j'indique au Sénat que nous les
reprendrons samedi après-midi et si vous
souhaitez clore cette discussion la
mener à son terme ce soir vraiment je je
vous prie instamment de pratiquer la
concision
absolue la discussion générale est
certainement un très grand moment de
débat parlementaire dans le cadre du
budget mais si nous pouvions la réduire
euh si vous pouvez faire l'économie de
vos interventions en discussion générale
ce sera naturellement un appauvrissement
du débat mais
euh nous y gagnerons en temps car je
crois que le moment interactif le plus
riche c'est la discussion des
amendements voilà le l'appel que je
souhaitais lancer madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est donc à philippe Dallier rapporteur
spécial de la commission des finances
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues cette
année la discussion budgétaire sur la
mission se focalisera n'en doutons pas
sur l'examen de l'article 919 de ce PLF
qui nous propose dans sa version
Assemblée nationale de créer un
prélèvement sur les organismes HLM pour
financer l'enrue à hauteur de 260
millions d'euros et les aides à la
pierre à hauteur de 80 millions pour
autant il serait regrettable de négliger
d'autres aspects de ce projet de budget
sur lesquels votre commission des
finances entend faire part de ces
observations vous me pardonnerez donc de
réserver mon propos sur l'article 99 à
son examen et de consacrer cette
intervention aux aspects strictement
budgétaires de la politique de la ville
et du Logement ces observations se
déclineront sous deux aspects le respect
de l'esprit de la LOLF et la sincérité
budgétaire si l'on examine la mission au
regard des principes de la LOLF et
notamment de son intention première qui
est bien de rendre le vote du budget par
le Parlement plus cohérent plus
transparent et plus intelligible il
n'est pas sûr que nous soyons après
plusieurs années sur la voie du progrès
d'abord parce que la mission avait une
cohérence forte à ses débuts qu'elle a
progressivement perdu si elle a gagné en
cohérence avec le rattachement du
programme 177 qui permet de relier
l'hébergement et le logement elle est
devenue une mission interministérielle
gérée aujourd'hui par un ministre et un
secrétaire d'État rattaché à un ministre
de tutelle différent je ne suis pas le
seul à regretter que le récent
remanement n'est pas été l'occasion d'un
retour à un ministère unifié
l'éclatement de la mission a en effet
des conséquences sur les agences
opérateurs de la mission et plus
particulièrement sur l'enrue qui relève
toujours du ministère de la Ville mais
dont les ressources sont principalement
fournies d'orénavant par le 1 % logement
qui est du domaine du secrétariat d'État
au Logement la seconde critique
lolfienne concerne le recours à des
financements extra buudgétaire qui prend
une ampleur inédite ce projet de budget
prévoit en effet une exceptionnelle
progr ression des fonds de concours leur
montant attend 13,13 million d'euros en
AE et 93,13 million d'euros en crédit de
paiement les fonds de concours sont même
devenus la clé de l'équilibre du
financement du programme développement
et amélioration de l'offre du logement
en permettant d'annuler l'écart entre
les autorisations d'engagement et les
crédits de paiement sur la ligne
fongible des aides à la pierre par un
apport de 80 millions d'euros en crédit
de paiement de palier l'impossibilité
dans laquelle la NAS se trouve d'assumer
la lutte contre l' état indigne dans le
casadre des travaux d'office dont elle a
pourtant doréavant la charge en
reversant au budget de l'État 10
millions d'euros en AE et en CP et enfin
d'atténuer la baisse des dépenses de
fonctionnement de l'administration
centrale du logement 3,13 million
d'euros en AE et en CP en principe
destiné à des actions de communication
sur la GRL en matière de financement
extra buudgétaire il n'est pas inutile
non plus de rappeler que les sommes
nécessaires à l'en rue pour passer la
fameuse bosse des années
2011-2014 viennent essentiellement
d'Action Logement et peut-être si la
proposition de la commission des
finances n'était pas adoptée du monde
HLM maintenant par un prélèvement de 260
millions à cette fin c'est donc sur le
principe de l'autorisation budgétaire
par le Parlement de son association à la
décision sur les dépenses publiques un
recul auquel nous assistons certains
pourraient se dire en période de
restriction budgétaire peu importe d'où
viennent les moyens pourvu qu'ils
existent oui mais mes chers collègues
ces pratiques sape la confiance des
acteurs de terrain de ces politiques
publiques acteurs qui ont besoin de
visibilité et pour tout dire mes chers
collègues quel dommage de brouiller
ainsi le message de l'État alors que le
PNRU est plébisité sur le terrain par
les maires quel qu'ils soi et que depuis
2 ans nous n'avons jamais autant financé
de logements sociaux puisque le chiffre
atteint est de 120000 par an contre
40000 en 2002 la seconde observation de
votre commission des finances concerne
la sincérité budgétaire là encore
monessieurs les ministres il existe une
grande marge de progression sur ce sujet
j'aurais pu choisir d'évoquer les aides
personnelles au logement pour lesquells
nous verrons bien si les mesures
d'économie que vous proposez dans ce PLF
et dans le PLFSS permettent de faire
face à leur évolution mais je préfère
retenir parmi d'autres l'exemple très
explicite des crédits du programme 177
prévention de l'exclusion et insertion
des personnes vulnérables nous avons
certes constaté la poursuite du rebasage
à la hausse de certaines dotations comme
celle destinée à au paiement des nuités
hôelières mais il est vrai cependant que
l'année dernière j'avais relevé
l'irréalisme d'une dotation en baisse de
plus de 40 %. je constate heureusement
que ce projet de budget est revenu à une
estimation plus sérieuse actant un
retour à un nombre de nuité sensiblement
égal à celui constaté pour 2009
c'est-à-dire 13000 pour un coût de 62
millions d'euros mais que ce soit sur
l'hébergement d'urgence ou l'aide
alimentaire les dépenses sont encore
trop systématiquement sous-évalué à cet
égard j'ai bien noté et je m'en félicite
que par amendement le gouvernement va
nous proposer d'augmenter de 17,3
millions d'euros les crédits destinés
aux maisons-rais et à l'aide alimentaire
cependant je ne suis pas tout à fait
certain que nous parviendrons même avec
cet apport conséquent à compenser la fin
du plan de relance qui avait contribué
très largement au financement de ces
actions l'année dernière 2èe remarque
concernant la sincérité budgétaire qui
touche le premier instrument de la
politique du logement la dépense fiscale
celle-ci comme chaque année est
largement supérieure à la dépense
budgétaire puisqu'elle s'élève à plus de
12 milliards d'euros en progression de
5,8 % par rapport à 2010 j'ai dénombré
68 dépenses fiscales rattachées à la
mission mais seul 40 font l'objet d'une
estimation l'insuffisance quantitative
de l'évaluation se double parfois
d'approximation méthodologique j'ai pu
le constater par exemple sur sur
l'évaluation de la dépense fiscale
correspondant au dégrèvement de taxes
d'habitation en faveur des personnes de
conditions modestes qui sont relogées
dans le cadre des projet en rue celle-ci
a été à mon sens très surestimée à
hauteur de 25 millions d'euros si je
prends l'exemple du dispositif le plus
emblématique le celler nous ne disposons
pas d'éléments sur la répartition
géographique des bénéficiaires ni sur la
nature des biens qui font l'objet de
cette niche fiscale peut-être utile mais
fort coûteuse la commission des finances
souhaite messieurs les ministres que vos
ministères et celui des finances se
rapprochent pour être en mesure de
fournir au Parlement des éléments
d'appréciation fiable la dernière
remarque que je rangerai sous la
rubrique sincérité budgétaire concerne
les dépenses les conséquences
financières de l'instauration du droit
au logement opposable notamment du fait
des condamnations de l'État dans les
deux premières années de son entrée en
vigueur le dalallo a eu pour conséquence
a eu des conséquences budgétaires
limitées au financement du du
fonctionnement des commissions de
médiation et de l'instruction des
dossiers les sommes budgétées étaient
resté globalement stabl à environ 5
million d'euros mais dans ce PLF elle
diminue à 4,7 millions en application de
la règle d'une diminution de 10 % sur 3
ans dont 5 % dès 2011 des crédits de
fonctionnement pour l'année prochaine
cette quasi stabilité des dépenses sera
rendue possible très certainement par le
maintien à 6 mois au lieu des 3 mois
prévus initialement du délai
d'instruction des dossiers dans les
grands agglomérations mais pour 2012
compte tenu de l'ouverture du dalallot à
l'ensemble des demandeurs de logements
sociaux non satisfaits dans les déadis
normaux il n'est pas réaliste
d'envisager une stabilisation des moyens
des commissions et encore moins leur
baisse mais l'application du dalallo
entraîne également des dépenses liées à
son contentieux paiement des asreintes
frit de justice condamnation pour
engagement de la responsabilité de
l'État l'année dernière je m'étais
préoccupé de l'absence de traduction
budgétaire de ces risques contentieux
et du maintien de la dotation à un
niveau de 700000 € or les bilans les
plus récents font état d'une progression
très rapide du montant des condamnations
prononcées contre l'État puisque le
montant des astreintes liquidé est passé
de
72860 € en 2009 à
6,731 millions d'euros au 30 septembre
2010 et devrait donc dépasser 10
millions d'euros en année pleine une
inscription budgétaire de 9,30 millions
en AE et en CP spécifique contentieux
d'Allo a donc été introduite dans ce
projet de budget et vient s'ajouter au
700000 € prévus pour les autres types de
contentieux cependant il semble que
cette évaluation à 10 millions d'euros
soit encore sous-estimée vous pourrez
sans doute monsieur le ministre nous en
dire plus et surtout nous convaincre que
l'État a désormais pris la mesure des
conséquences financières du dallo dans
la perspective de 2012 monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je m'aperçois que j'ai été que
j'ai beaucoup évoqué les actions propres
logement bien que je n'ai pas abordé la
réforme de l'accession à la propriété
qui sera traitée lors de l'examen de
l'article 56 mais qui n'est pas rattaché
à la mission et que j'ai très peu si ce
n'est pas du tout parlé des actions qui
relèvent du ministre de la Ville c'est
sans doute que cette politique est
devenue si résiduel au point de vue
budgétaire qu'il n'y a malheureusement
pas grandchose à en dire sauf à saluer
la détermination et le travail des
agents de l'accès qui parviennent à
améliorer l'efficacité de leurs
interventions tout en accomplissant les
efforts économie qui leur sont demandé
pour le reste monsieur le ministre
réforme de la géographie prioritaire
révision des procédures contractuell
renouvellement ou sortie aménager des
afus coordination de l'action des
agences résurrection du CIV affirmation
de l'autorité du secrétariat général
voilà 2 ans que nous attendons des
décisions malheureusement reporté de
mois en mois votre tâche monsieur le
ministre sera rude et sous le bénéfice
de ces observations et des deux
amendements que je vous présente entrée
votre commission des finances vous
demande d'adopter les crédits de la
mission ville et logement 10 minutes
merci mon chers collègu la parole est à
Monsieur Dominique braille en
remplacement de Monsieur pierre- André
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
l'économie
oui madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
l'économie notre collègue Pierre-André
étant dans l'impossibilité de prendre la
parole ce soir en raison d'une petite
intervention au niveau des cordes de
vocal il m'a demandé de le remplacer ce
soir il a sûrement fait d'ailleurs en
sachant que je disposais d'un organe
suffisant pour faire entendre sa voix
mais aussi mais aussi en raison je le
sais des liens amicaux qui nous lit
c'est donc bien l'intervention de
Pierre-André que vous entendrez
intervention à laquelle je n'ai
naturellement changé aucune virgule
permettez-moi tout d'abord de vous
féliciter monsieur le ministre pour
votre nomination permettez-moi d'ajouter
aussi et monsieur le secrétaire d'État
au logement pour votre reconduction
comme l'ont annoncé donc le président de
la République et le Premier ministre la
politique de la ville doit être revu
sachez monsieur le ministre que vous
pourrez compter sur le soutien et
l'expertise de la commission de
l'économie je ne reviendrait pas sur les
crédits du programme 147 politique de la
ville inscrit au projet de loi de
finances pour 2011 qui ont déjà été
présentés par le rapporteur spécial de
la commission des finances la conomie la
commission de l'économie a donné un avis
favorable à l'adoption des crédits de la
mission ville et logement je souhaite
évoquer aujourd'hui deux sujets très
importants l'avenir du programme
national de rénovation urbaine le PNRU
et la révision de la géographie
prioritaire lancé en 2003 le PNRU s'est
vu fixer des objectifs très ambitieux il
s'agit sur la période
2004-2013 d'atteindre dans les quartiers
concernés 250000 logements locatifs
sociaux nouveaux 400000 logements
locatifs sociaux réhabilités 400000
logements sociaux résidentialisés et
250000 logements locatifs sociaux
démolis même si les objectifs fixés
initialement ne seront certainement pas
atteints le bilan du PNRU est très
positif au 1er octobre plus de 380
conventions ont été signées l'enrue
estime que 4 190 quartiers seront
rénovés à l'horizon 2013 améliorant
ainsi le cadre de vie de près de 4
millions de nos concitoyens le PNRU a eu
un effet levier très important le
montant total des investissements
devrait dépasser les 40 milliards
d'euros enfin et surtout le PNRU a un
véritable impact dans les quartiers
concernés il a remis en mouvement des
territoires qui n'avaient plus de
réelles perspectiv d'évolution et
d'espoir mais que se passera-t-il après
2013 j'estime qu'il est indispensable
monsieur le ministre de réfléchir au
lancement d'un deuxème programme de
rénovation urbaine un PNRU 2 deux
remarques cependant un PNRU 2 ne peut
être lancé que si le financement du P
pneru 1 est assuré je salue le travail
remarquable de notre commission des
finances qui a su trouver dans le cadre
du présent projet de loi de finance une
solution équilibrée permettant d'assurer
le financement de l'an rue jusqu'en 2013
sans pénaliser les organismes HLM la
rénovation urbaine n'est qu'un aspect de
la politique de la ville les politiques
économique et social ne doivent pas être
négligés comme le soulignait le Premier
ministre dans le valdoise le 8 novembre
dernier je cite la rénovation urbaine ce
n'est pas seulement les murs c'est
l'emploi c'est l'éducation c'est la
sécurité ce sont les infrastructures de
transport s'agissant de la réforme de la
géographie prioritaire elle a été
repoussée par le Premier ministre à
l'année 2011 je salue cette décision qui
permet que toutes les questions soient
mises sur la table et qu'un grand débat
national puisse s'engager ce grand
chantier nécessite en effet le concours
de tous la révision de la géographie
prioritaire doit conduire selon moi au
passage de la logique actuelle de zonage
à une logique de
contractualalisation les différents
dispositifs existants seraient ainsi
remplacés par un contrat unique signé
entre le maire ou le président de le PCI
et le préfet adossé à la durée du mandat
municipal afin de renforcer l'efficacité
de la politique de la ville il m'a
paraît également nécessaire de
concentrer les moyens de l'État sur les
communes les plus en difficultés je
pense que les les recommandations que
nous avions formulé avec Gérard amamel
dans le rapport que nous avez confié le
Premier ministre sont aujourd'hui assez
largement partagés votre nomination à la
tête d'un ministère de plein exercice se
situe d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre
dans la droite ligne de notre rapport en
conclusion j'espère que l'année 2011
sera mise à profit pour organiser le
grand débat national que j'appelle de
mes vœux je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Thierry Repentin rapporteur pour avis de
la commission de
l'économie
madame la Présidente Monsieur le les
ministre mes chers collègues je ne
reviendrai pas longuement sur
l'évolution des crédits de la mission
ville et logement qui vous a déjà été
présenté par le rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances il y a quelques
minutes les trois programmes relatifs au
logement voi en 2011 leur crédit
augmenté légèrement de 0,7 % d'
autorisation d'engagement et reculé de
1,6 % en crédit de paiement l'évolution
des crédits est différenciée selon les
programmes le programme 177 prévention
de l'exclusion et insertion des
personnes vulnérables voit ces crédits
augmenté de 7,5 %. le programme 108 aide
à l'axcé à logement voit ses crédits
diminuer de 1,6 % et le programme 135
développement et amélioration de l'offre
de logement voit ses crédit augmenté de
9,3 % en AE et diminué de 17,7 % en CP
je relève que le programme 177
prévention de l'exclusion ass des
personnes vulnérables et cette année
encore d'autres l'ont dit sous-budgtisé
puisque les crédits inscrits pour 20111
sont inférieurs au crédit consommés en
2009 s'agissant du programme 108 qui
regroupe essentiellement les aides
personnelles au logement je m'étonne
qu'il voit ses crédits diminuer alors
qu'en pleine période de crise la
situation de nos compatriotes devrait
conduire au contraire à une augmentation
des crédits destinés aux aides au
logement je souhaite cependant
concentrer mon propos sur l'évolution
des crédits destinés aux aides à la
pierre le fameux programme 135 couvre en
effet essentiellement ces aides il
permet donc de mesurer l'effort
budgétaire de l'État pour la
construction et la réhabilitation des
logements sociaux je souhaite faire
plusieurs remarques premièrement les
perspectives d'évolution du niveau des
aides à la pierre sont inquiettantes les
crédits du programme 135 devrai ainsi
diminuer en 2012 et en 2 13 pour passer
de 518 millions d'euros en CP en 2011 à
459 en 2012 à 387 en 2013 deuxièmement
je m'inquiète donc du désengagement de
l'État en matière de construction de
logements sociaux les crédits de la
ligne fongi devrait être renforcé par
les ressources issues du dispositif mise
en place on le verra par l'article 99 à
hauteur de 150 millions d'euros si nous
adoptons tout à l'heure l'amendement de
notre rapporteur spécial je regrette
cependant ant que les bailleurs sociaux
soient mobilisés afin de compenser la
diminution de crédit budgétaire
c'est-à-dire issu de l'État
troisièmement alors que l'État se
désengage je tiens néanmoins à la
tribune à souligner l'effort croissant
des collectivités territoriales en
matière de logement d'après les données
du ministère cet effort est ainsi passé
de 430 millions en 2000 à près de 1,8
milliard d'euros en 2009 et ils ont cru
depuis quatrièmement dernière remarque
les objectifs du gouvernement en matière
de de construction de logements sociaux
sont ambitieux 120000 en 2011 contre
110000 en 2010 au vu de l'évolution des
dotations je ne peux donc que
m'inquiéter que l'on aboutisse à une
réduction sensible des subventions
unitaires moyennes une telle évolution
ayant été une constante au cours des
dernières années en conclusion j'estime
donc à titre personnel que ce budget ne
répond pas aux enjeux auxquels est
confronté notre pays notamment en
matière de logement social et je partage
le point de vue exprimé par Jérôme
Bédier le président de l'Union
d'économie sociale pour le logement qui
indiquait le 8 novembre dernier je cite
que ce n'est pas à Bery de gérer la
politique du logement en France
néanmoins et malgré mes réserve la
commission de l'économie comme c'est
désormais une tradition a émis un avis
favorable à l'adoption des crédits de la
mission ville et logement s'agissant de
l'article 99 sur lequel j'interviendrai
tout à l'heure titre personnel la
commission de l'économie a émis un avis
favorable à son adoption sous réserve de
l'amendement de la commission des
finances je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Marie van lenberg rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des Affaires
social monsieur les
ministres monsieur le madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues
comme le ministre les rapporteurs
spéciaux ont déjà présenté les grands
axes de ce projet de budget 2011 pour la
mission ville et logement je souhaite au
nom de la commission des affaires
sociales me concentrer sur trois points
précis d'abord l'enjeu général du budget
de cette mission le défi auquel le
gouvernement et le Parlement sont
confrontés n'est pas facile puisqu'il
s'agit de respecter la norme de
réduction des dépenses publiques moins
10 % sur les d'intervention tout en
maintenant la vitalité de la politique
du logement et la cont continuité pardon
de la politique de la ville je crois que
d'une manière générale l'objectivité
oblige à reconnaître que les
propositions initiales du texte amélioré
par l'Assemblée nationale sont pour la
plupart raisonnables et que pour
certaines d'entre elles elles restent
malheureusement
contestables certains d'entre vous
dénonceront par exemple j'en suis sûr la
baisse des aides à la pierre on vient de
l'entendre ou celle des crédits de
contrat urbain de cohésion sociale
lescuc je leur dire ceci au regard de
l'endettement de l'État qui atteint un
record historique de 1600 milliards
d'euros soit près de 92 82 % pardon du
PIB était-il possible de faire autrement
je ne le crois pas et j'apprécie
particulièrement dans ce contexte les
capacités notamment
d'intervention dans la politique de la
ville soit relativement préservé
j'apprécierai néanmoins monsieur le
monsieur le ministre que la géographie
prioritaire trouve enfin un
aboutissement vous savez qu'elle doit
être révisée mais on l'attend depuis
fort longtemps il me semble au contraire
que le véritable enjeu des prochaines
années ce n'est pas la légitimité de
l'effort national qui est vital pour
l'avenir du pays mais la répartition de
cet effort entre nos concitoyens et
entre nous tous or monsieur le ministre
c'est précisément sur ce point que
certains choix du gouvernement sont
discutables et ce sera la deuxème partie
de mon
intervention je ne prendrai qu'un seul
exemple mais qui me paraît
significatif celui du prê à tau zéro
universel je sais bien que techniquement
parlant il n'est pas rattaché à la
mission mais qui contestera qu'il relève
de la politique d'accès au logement ce
prêt à tau zéro le gouvernement l'a
voulu universel ouvert à tous quel que
soit le niveau de revenu comme le crédit
d'impôt sur les emprunts immobiliers
qu'il remplacera à partir de l'année
prochaine
pourquoi un tel choix pour pourquoi
avoir maintenu un dispositif aveugle au
niveau des revenus le gouvernement
pense-t-il vraiment monsieur le ministre
qu'une personne ou un ménage qui
bénéficie de ressources élevées 10000 ou
15000 € par mois doit doivent être aidés
par la collectivité est-il juste que
l'État sans dette pour aider les ménages
les plus aisés à accéder à la
propriété je n'en suis pas convaincu
pour ne pas dire le contraire et à vrai
dire je pense que personne que peu de
personnes le sont
oui nous devons collectivement faire des
efforts pour désendetter le pays pour ne
pas hypothéquer son avenir sur les
marchés financiers mais ces efforts
voire ces sacrifices qui sont
aujourd'hui demandés ne pourront être
accepté que s'ils sont équitablement
répartis je crois profond
que le redressement de notre pays ne
pourra se faire que dans la justice
sociale mais la justice sociale je le
dis aussi clairement c'est pas forcément
la dépense publique il faut le dire à
nos concitoyens qui n'en sont pas tout à
fait conscients dans la politique du
logement et de la ville comme ailleurs
la seule réponse crédible c'est
l'innovation inventer de nouveaux
dispositifs ingénieux efficace et moins
coûteux tel est sans doute la voix de
modernisation que notre pays peut
emprunter c'est dans cet esprit que la
commission des affaires sociales vous
proposera cette année un amendement
adopté à l'unanimité qui vise à
promouvoir la garantie des risques
locatifs la GRL nous en reparlemons le
rond pardon au moment de la discussion
des amendements mais je souhaite le dire
tout de suite la GRL est un dispositif
innovant inventé par les partenaires
sociaux qui vise à faciliter l'accès au
logement pour des personnes en situation
de précarité en en éliminant le risque
financier encouru par le bailleur
lorsqu'il loue son logement à ses
personnes à ce jour sont près de 200000
ménages qui sont couverts par la GRL
dont 68 % peuvent être considéré comme
précaire c'està direire CDD chômeurs
étudiants et qui n'auraiit donc pas
trouvé de logement dans le parc privé
sans la GRN encore faut-il encore
faudrait-il que ce risque soit mutualisé
et que tous les assureurs le proposent
de risques pour conclure en tenant
compte de la subvention de chiffres
pardon je dis deis en tenant compte de
la subvention budgétaire des aides
fiscales et des aides de taux ou de
circuit un logement HLM standard coûte
aujourd'hui en moyenne
34500 € à l'état la subvention
d'équilibre par logement couvert par la
GRL 300 dans les deux cas l'aide
publique permet de loger une personne en
situation de précarité mais vous
apprécierez la différence je parlais
tout à l'heure de contenir les dépenses
publiqu sans renoncer à la justice
sociale je crois que la GRL et
l'amendement de la commission vous
propose et montre que cela est possible
nous avons les outils à nous de prendre
nos responsabilités ceci dit pour
conclure la commission soutiendra et
émet un avis favorable à la politique de
la ville et du du logement merci chers
collègues je vous rappelle que le temps
de parole attribué à chaque groupe pour
chaque discussion comprend le temps
d'intervention générale et celui de
l'explication de vote je vous rappelle
qu'en application des décisions de la
conférence des présidents aucune
intervention des orateurs de groupe ne
doit dépasser 10 minutes par ailleurs le
gouvernement dispose au total de 20
minutes pour
intervenir la parole est à Monsieur
Jacques
mzard
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues pour
répondre à la recommandation de monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances mes convictions se résoudront à
à trois points le premier c'est la
politique de la ville les crédits sont
en baisse de 13 % pour les autorisations
d'engagement de 12 % pour les crédits de
paiement
vous diminuez monsieur le ministre
fortement la dotation versée à l'Agence
nationale pour la cohésion sociale et si
les contrats urbains sont prorogés lescx
jusqu'en 2013 je crois que c'est le
cadeau d'adieu de Madame Amara c'est
avec une diminution annuelle des crédits
d'état de 10 % ce qui imposera en
réalité aux collectivités locales de
compenser pour continuer à mener nombre
action dans les quartiers ça c'est la
traduction sur le
terrain 2è point en ce qui concerne les
aides à la pierre rapporteur a relevé
tout à l'heure la baisse et l'injustice
du nouveau système vous remplacez le
passe-foncier usé avant d'avoir servi le
prêt à taux zéro et le crédit d'impôt
sur les intérêts d'emprunt par un
nouveau prêt à taux zéro dont
l'injustice vient d'être dénoncée c'est
plus lisible mais votre nouveau système
de pré àau zéro pénalise très fortement
les accédentss à la propriété en zone C
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le rappeler
le recentrage de la politique du
logement sur les zones les plus tendues
a des effets
pervers car sur nombre de ces
territoires de la zone C les revenus des
ménages sont souvent le plus souvent
plus bas que dans nombre d'agglomération
car c'est l'adéquation entre prix et
revenu qui est en réalité é déterminante
3è
observation sur l'article 99 du projet
de loi de finances comme il est indiqué
dans le rapport de notre collègue
Philippe daller ce ne peut-être qualifié
d'instrument de
péréquation dans la mesure où son
assiette est constituée de la masse des
loyers perçus elle
s'appliquerait indifféremment et
uniformément à tous les organismes quel
que soit leur situation financière mais
même ce dispositif revu par l'amendement
qui nous est proposé par le rapporteur
aura sur le terrain des conséquences
catastrophiques pour nombre d'organismes
HLM en particulier dans nos petits
département où ces organismes qu'ils soi
société anonyme ou office sont les
moteurs de la construction de logement
en l'absence il faut le rappeler en
l'absence quasit tot dans ces
territoires de promoteurs privés j'ai
fais un calcul pour un organisme que je
connais et sur un résultat de 1,3
million d'euros environ chaque année la
ponction serait d'environ 1 million
d'euros c'est-à-dire que ça détruit
toute possibilité d'action de cet
organisme voilà les trois observations
que je voulais le faire monsieur le
Président j'ai essayé d'être en accord
avec vos recommandations et dans ces
conditions
mieurs les ministres il ne vous étonnera
point que la majorité de mon groupe ne
vote pas cette mission merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame Odette
terade madame la Présidente messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues malgré
une crise du logement sans précédent
forceé de constater que ce projet de loi
de finan n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux pire encore il entérine le
désengagement de l'État de ce secteur
relevant pourtant de l'intérêt général
et de la solidarité nationale messieurs
les ministre vous connaissez les
chiffres comme moi 3 mil00on et demi de
personnes dont 600000 enfants sont
aujourd'hui en situation de mallogement
1200000 personnes attendent un logement
social 100000 sont sans domicile fisque
et 500000 privés de logement personnel
parmi elles 100000 vivent à l'hôtel et
100000 dans des campings il s'agit là
d'une situation drama que qui heurte nos
principes républicains et devrait
appeler d'urgence à un engagement
national pour le logement mais cette
prise de conscience n'est pas celle du
gouvernement qui ne connaît comme
politique publique que celle de la
rigueur à ce titre la présentation du
budget est assez claire je cite par des
mesures financières en matière fiscale
et budgétaire qui sont mises en œuvre
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finance la mission ville et logement
participe à l'objectif de réduction des
déficits publics ainsi
tous les programmes de cette mission
sont en régression en crédit de paiement
à l'exception du programme 177 ces
coupes atteignent même - 18 % pour les
aides à la pierre - 12 % pour la
politique de la ville cet effort se
place dans une démarche pérenne puisque
les crédit de la mission devrait perdre
48 millions en 2012 et 61 millions en
2013 je commencerai cette intervention
par la confrontation de deux chiffres
qui il me semble sont particulièrement
éclairants des priorités de ce
gouvernement les aides à la pierre les
aides directes à la pierre ne
représentent plus en crédit de paiement
que 469 millions à l'inverse les
dispositifs fiscaux atteignent eux 12
milliards d'euros nous ne pouvons alors
que constater un glissement des aides de
l'État en faveur de la construction de
logements sociaux vers un système de
financement de la construction poussant
à la création d'un marché du logement
lucratif ainsi 40 % des aides publiques
de l'État vont au logement privé 30 % au
propriétaire et 30 % logement social en
d'autres termes 70 % des investissements
sont orientés vers le secteur privé
aujourd'hui ce gouvernement annonce
comme un progrès la mise en chantier de
120000 logements soit 10000 de plus que
l'année précédente mais selon les
chiffres du rapport de la Fondation
abbépierre ce sont 900000 logements
qu'il faudrait construire pour répondre
à la demande ce budget enterrine donc la
sous-production de logement et nous ne
pouvons l'admettre concernant le
programme 177 prévention de l'exclusion
et insertion des personnes vulnérables
si les crédits sont globalement en
augmentation force de constater que
comme le note très justement le
rapporteur de la commission des finances
la trajectoire retenue pour les trois
prochaines années et celle d'une
réduction progressive des crédits
budgétaires nous ne sommes donc à ce
titre agréablement surpris de
l'amendement déposé par le Gouvernement
qui tend à remédier à la sous-dotation
qui affectait les crédits de l'aide
aliment ainsi que ceux des organismes
qui logent les personnes
défavorisées le programme 109 lui est
constitué par les aides au logement ce
programme est très important puisqu'il a
concerné plus de 6,3 millions de foyers
en 2009 et qu'il représente
5,277
milliards ce ces crédits sont pourtant
en baisse de 84 millions je rappelle que
nous demandant régulièrement une
revalorisation de 20 % du niveau de laap
afin de mettre en cohérence ce
dispositif avec l'évolution du coût de
la vie d'autre part je ne peux passer
sous silence le scandaleux mécanisme
permettant la non rétroactivité du
versement des aPL entre le moment de la
demande et celui de la mise en œuvre par
la CAF mécanisme voté lors du dernier
PLF FSS une telle mesure devrait
permettre de réaliser une économie de
240 millions d'euros sur les plus
fragiles pour nous cette décision est
une honte alors même que la crise
sociale et économique jette dans la
précarité un nombre de famille de plus
en plus important concernant le
programme 135 développement et
amélioration de l'offre de logement les
crédits paiements sont en baisse de 18 %
teignant même une diminution de 22 %
pour la seule action construction
locative et amélioration du parc une
telle diminution est réalisée grâce à
une opération de passp permettant un
recours plus important au fond de
concours fond de concours devenant la
clé de voûe de ce programme en réalité
cet apport extra buudgétaire a été
imaginé
initialement par une ponction réalisée
sur les HLM à hauteur de 340 millions
par an sur 3 ans je parle ici du fameux
article 99 qui propose de ponctionner
les ressources des offices HLM pour
financer à la fois l'en rue et compenser
la baisse des aides à la pierre je
réaffirme notre indignation et notre
colère cette mesure présentée comme la
suppression d'une niche fiscale est un
holdup sur les moyens du logement social
l'USH estimait en l'état que cette taxe
ferait baisser de 20000 le nombre de
logements chaque année ainsi et ce
malgré la nouvelle proposition du
rapporteur de limiter la recette attendu
de cette ponction à 150 millions le
financement des aides à la pierre ne
serait plus au final assuré par la
solidarité nationale mais bien par les
offices et les locataires nous
proposerons donc tout simplement la
suppression de cet article que dire
également des perspectives financières
pour les 3 années à venir que vous
proposez en faisant passer les crédits
des ailes à la pierre de 790 millions en
2008 à seulement 400 millions en 2013 il
faut également noter dans ce programme
une diminution sévère de la subvention
moyenne par logement plus passant de
1000 à 800 € et de 12000 à 10760 € pour
les plai ainsi la participation de
l'État aux nouvelles construction de
logements sociaux aura diminué de moitié
au cours des dernières années alors que
l'effort des offices HLM est passé lui
de 2 5 % à 12 % en maintenant ces
crédits en diminution l'État entend
ainsi continuer de reporter les besoins
au financement des opération sur les
autres intervenants collectivité locale
Action Logement organisme HLM pourtant
les collectivités sont en grande
difficulté du fait de la suppression de
la taxe professionnelle il leur sera
donc difficile de maintenir un tel
niveau d'effort et je ne parle même pas
de l'EN rue qui est au bord de la
cessation de paiement la conclusion est
donc sans appel on continuera on
construira moins avec moins d'argent
parallèlement nous ne disposons pas des
éléments nous permettant d'apprécier
l'efficacité de la dépense fiscale
faramineuse plus importante même que les
crédits de la mission ces exonérations
atteignent des sommets à 12 milliards
d'euros cette année soit une progression
de 5,8 %. c'est dans ce contexte que
Nicolas Sarkozi reformule son espoir
d'une France de propriétaire notamment
par le biais de nouveau PTZ Plus prévu à
l'article 56 de la loi de finance devant
se substituer à trois outils le PTZ le
passe foncier la déduction des crédits
d'emprunt ce PTZ Plus devrait conduire à
une économie de 2,5 milliards en 2018
c'est donc pour les membres de la
majorité une bonne disposition mais nous
l'avons régulièrement dit comment
favoriser l'accession à la propriété
alors même que le niveau de vie est en
baisse constante que la précarité dans
le travail se généralise que l'État
renonce à la maîtrise foncière afin de
limiter la spéculation qui se développe
à qui profitera donc ce PTZ si ce n'est
aux banques qui se sont déjà
honteusement gavés durant la crise qui
aujourd'hui peut devenir propriétaire
sans s'en dé sur plusieurs générations
nous vous l'avons dit nous le répétons
ceelus n'a d'autre objet que de
justifier le désengagement de l'état du
logement social je termine madame la
Présidente parallèlement à un budget peu
ambitieux tout un arsenal législatif est
mis en place par ce gouvernement afin de
réformer les prescription appliqué au
logement dans l'objectif d'en dévoyer la
mission ainsi derrière les annonces sur
les aides à l'accession la propriété sur
la suppression de la rétroactivité des
versements des aPL l'application du
surloyer ou encore les nouveaux risques
pesant sur la part du livra revenant à
la Caisse des Dépôts c'est bien la casse
du logement social qui se profile et
parce que cette loi de finance ne permet
pas d'entrevoir ce qui pourrait être un
grand service public de l'habitat nous
voterons contre les crédits de cette
mission merci chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Alain
Foucher
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues
simplement quelques
mots à la fois pour parler des finances
et peut-être aussi de de justice sociale
quelques inquiétudes naturellement sur
les taxations des office d' HLM c'est
pour cette raison que je souhaite
obtenir quelques précisions cette
taxation effectivement sur pompe propre
slvé à 150 million d'euros mais quels
sont monsieur le ministre les critères
retenus prendrez-vous en compte les
conventions en rue et les fonds propres
que les organismes investissent sur le
long terme prendrez-vous également en
compte les nouvelles normes imposé par
le Grenel aux acteurs du logement social
sur le traitement des épaves thermiques
que des offices d'HLM qui font des
réserves des crédits importants soit
taxés oui au regarde la crise du
logement mais ceux qui ont une véritable
politique d'investissement ne doivent
pas être pénalisé dans leurs efforts de
construction car la dynamique du
mouvement Hlm serait stoppée deuxème
point que je souhaite aborder qui
préoccupe un certain nombre d'élus c'est
l'article 55 de la loi SRU qui impose
aux communes de plus de 3500 habitants
intégrés dans une agglomération d'au
moins 50000 habitants un quotat de 20 %
en construction de logements sociaux sur
5 ans
certains maires de différents horizons
politiques s'opposent à cette règle ils
ont peur de récupérer toute la misère du
monde ou d'autres pour le choix de payer
l'amende pour des visés é élector
abérrante selon ses élus la clientèle
aisée préféré aux personnes à fables
ressources qui peuvent avoir besoin de
plus de soutien
socio-éducatif mais qui pourtant apporte
cette richesse populaire essence de
notre pacte républicain nous sommes sur
ces bancs convaincus du besoin en
logement et de la nécessité d'en
construire pour tous c'est pourquoi il
faut inciter voir obliger ces centaines
de communes viser qui n'atteignent pas
ce taux à engager un plan de rattrapage
à cet effet monsieur le ministre ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il faudrait envisager
un relèvement du montant de la
contribution de solidarité d par ces
communes
récalcitrantes actuellement le montant
de C sanction reste inférieur au coût de
construction des logements sociaux il
est donc préféré par certaines équipes
municipales de payer plutôt que de
construire et je trouve que c'estci tout
à fait scandaleux je souhaite avoir
monsieur le ministre une réponse sur ce
point merci beaucoup merci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
pierre
Jarlier
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues malgré les
efforts collectif de ces dernières
années notamment au travers du Plan de
Cohésion Sociale auquel ont été aussi
fortement associé toutes les
collectivités la crise du logement est
de plus en plus préoccupante la France
compte aujourd'hui 3,3 millions de mal
logés alors que le besoin en logement
est évalué à 950000 l'offre de logement
est en rétractation avec 305000 mises en
chantier en 2009 un recul de 17 % par
rapport à 2008 or le logement est un
bien de première nécessité auquel chacun
a droit et selon les dernières données
du comité de suivi de la loi d'Allo le
nombre de recours est en très forte
progression ces derniers mois dans ce
contexte le projet de budget présenté
par le gouvernement doit résoudre une
équation difficile préserver la vitalité
de la politique du logement tout en
respectant l'impératif de réduction de
notre déficit public l'État a donc été
conduit à revoir ses priorités pour
répondre d'abord aux attentes dans les
secteurs les plus tendus si le principe
de ce ciblage est justifié il doit aussi
être pertinent et
équilibré s'agissant du logement social
le gouvernement a annoncé la
réorientation des aides à la pierre vers
les territoires en tension afin de mieux
ajuster la production à la demande
effective des ménages cette nouvelle
priorité suscite de nombreuses
inquiétudes notamment au zones c ça a
été dit par plusieurs de mes collègues à
titre d'exemple les territoires les plus
défavorisés qui ont un PIB un peu peu
élevé compte une part importante de
population à très faible revenu qui vit
très souvent en HLM c'est le cas de
certaines villes ou de certaines
communes situées en zones rurales qui ne
sont pourtant pas considéré comme des
zones tendues le soutien à la
construction de logements sociaux doit
donc être adapté à la réalité et la
diversité des territoires plus qu'un
zonage décidé de façon centralisée il
serait donc pertinent de s'appuyer sur
les comités régionaux de l'habitat je
l'ai déjà dit plusieurs fois monsieur le
ministre avec vous lors de plusieurs
débats en lien avec les acteurs locaux
pour définir au plus près du territoire
les besoins en logement cette démarche
serait d'autant plus légitime que les
programmes locaux de l'habitat se
généralisent peu à peu et les
informations issues du terrain sont de
plus en plus précise cette remarque vaut
aussi pour les aides au logement en
direction du parc privé qui privilégie
là encore la construction en zone tendue
et favorise davantage dans les autres
territoires la réhabilitation et la
rénovation s'agissant de la réforme des
aides de an elle tente à renforcer le
soutien à la rénovation chez les
propriétaires occupants à faible revenu
et nous devons encourager cet effort
mais du côté mais du côté des
propriétaires bailleurs le dispositif
relatif à la prime réduction de loyers
en zone tendu Ana risque là encore de
provoquer la réduction du nombre de
conventions de catégorie social ou trait
social dans les zones rurales non
tendues de ce fait les propriétaires
bailleurs risquent de ne plus intervenir
pour réhabiliter leur parc locatif en
direction du logement social en
l'absence d'encouragement au
conventionnement comme cela a été évoqué
au sein du conseiltion conseil
d'administration de l'ANA le nouveau
dispositif méritera donc d'être évalué
rapidement pour être là encore adapté si
nécessaire à la diversité des
territoires le dernier point que je
souhaite évoquer rapidement porte sur
l'article 99 du projet de loi pour
compenser la baisse des aides à la
pierre le projet de loi de finance
initial prévoit un recours au fond de
concours à hauteur de 93 millions parmi
ces sources de financement 80 millions
d'euros devait provenir de la mise en
place d'une contribution sur les revenus
locatifs prélevé sur les organismes HLM
et dont le montant total slevé à 340
millions répondant aux inquiétudes des
organismes HNM et des élus la commission
des finances du Sénat a dans un premier
temps légitimement supprimer cette
disposition alors que dans le même temps
un nouveau dispositif était proposé par
l'Assemblée nationale c'est une nouvelle
version de la taxe sur les dos du dorm
institué en 2009 qui a été adopté mais
il est utile de rappeler pour la suite
de nos débats que cette taxe qui porte
sur les réserves financières non
utilisées par les bailleurs sociaux a
été un échec car pour y échapper les
organismes HLM ont réduit leur potentiel
financier notamment en remboursant leurs
dettes notre commission des finances sur
proposition du rapporteur général
Philippe Marini et du rapporteur spécial
philippe Dallier nous propose la
réduction du prélèvement sur les
organismes HLM de 340 à 150 millions
d'euros cette somme ramenée à un niveau
acceptable sera consacrée exclusivement
au développement Etam du parc de
logements sociaux c'est une avancée
significative que je tiens à saluer
cette proposition fait également évoluer
la définition du potentiel financier
pour en écarter les subventions versées
par les collectivités les efforts
consentis par celles-ci en faveur du
logement social seront donc préservés
toutefois il faut aussi veiller à ce que
le critère retenu du potentiel financier
ne pénalise pas les organismes HLM les
plus fragiles en effet certains d'entre
eux ont un potentiel financier élevé
alors qu'ils sont très endettés et
qu'ils ont un autofinancement également
très faible cette remarque a fait
l'objet de plusieurs sous-amendements
qui je l'espère seront pris en compte je
m'en tiendrai là pour ne pas retarder
les débats et je vous remercie de votre
attention merci chers collègues la
parole est à Madame
barisakari
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
rapporteurs messieurs les ministres
chers collègues il y a 5 ans les
banlieux s'embrasaient ce n'était pas la
première fois certes mais nous avons
observé un degré de violence inédit
traduisant le mal-être de ces quartiers
et plus inquiétant aucun déboucher
politique n'a été offert aucun
desboucher politique n'a été proposé
nous connaissons tous les problèmes de
ces territoire nous sommes conscients
des difficultés de ces quartiers qui ont
mal vieilli qui sont mal intégrés au
reste de la ville je pense que personne
dans cet hémicycle ne peut se dire
insensible à la détresse des populations
bien souvent marginalisé pour ne pas
dire abandonné dans ces quartiers les
services publics sont peu présents en
général le chômage est fort le sentiment
d'injustice constant pourtant le
programme 147 politique de la ville
accuse une baisse de ses crédits il
représente 618 millions en autorisation
d'engagement et environ la même somme en
crédit de paiement dans le détail les
autorisations baissent de 13 % et les
crédits de 12 %. le budget est contraint
cette année le gouvernement veut montrer
qu'il fait des économies pire la baisse
constatée ici est supérieure à la norme
d'économie retenue lors de l'élaboration
du budget cette affirmation n'est pas de
moi elle est de notre collègue
Dallier ainsi donc devant un tel
désengagement je dois en conclure que le
plan Espoir banlieu qui n'a jamais eu de
moyen n'était qu'un simple affichage
destiné à calmer la colère de ces
populations sans rien changer sur le
fond le budget 2010 était déjà
criticable celui de 2011 donne carrément
dans le cynisme et le mépris le plan de
Fadela Amara porte somme toute bien son
nom espoir vous souhaitez volontiers que
les habitants de ces quartiers en
restent à l'espoir d'une vie meilleure
parce qu'en fait vous ne leur accordez
rien la preuve la plus flagrante et la
diminution de la ligne porte sur les
dynamiques espoir banlieu il suffit de
regarder au sein des crédits affectés à
l'Agence nationale pour la cohésion
sociale et l'égalité des chances eux-
mêmes en baissent de 10 %. cette ligne
est inférieure au montant de 2010 certes
mais aussi à la ligne de 2000 au budget
de 2009 c'est d'autant plus dramatique
que tout que tout retard allongera
Infiné le montant de la facture
cherche-t-on à paupériser à gooiser
davantage ces quartiers je je ne
souhaite faire de procès d'intention
mais les faits sont là vous faites une
politique d'affichage avec le plan
Espoir banlieu tandis que dans le même
temps vous réduisez drastiquement les
crédits disponibles pour les quartiers
les tendances sont inquiétantes en 2009
le budget était déjà en diminution le
plan Espoir banlieu n'était soutenu que
par Madame Amara il faut reconnaître
qu'elle portait seu cet espoir en 2010
il baisse à nouveau bat les masques
finit de jouer le rideau du carnaval
tombe sur une è représentation où la
banlieu aura été mise au premier plan
pour mieux la ridiculiser à ce niveau-là
on retrouvera des opérations de
rénovation urbaine où il sera question
de repeindre les bâtiments pour donner
l'impression aux habitants qu'on
s'occupe d'eux manifestement vous n'avez
pas vous n'avez compris ni l'urgence de
la situation ni le besoin d'un
changement complet de politique de la
ville ce budget est indécent par rapport
à ces quartiers je suis d'autant plus
inquiète que la première génération des
zones franches urbaines arrive à
échéance le 31 décembre 2011 la
revitalisation économique de ces espaces
est une question cruciale n n nous ne
pouvons pas la palser sous silence pour
l'heure je constate que les données
ayant conduit à la la création des a fu
existent encore ce qui devrait nous
inciter à réfléchir à une manière de
poursuivre ce système et non pas d'en
sortir brutalement il aurait été
souhaitable de commencer à réfléchir dès
cette année aux modalités d'évolution
des aides à fu et non d'attendre de se
trouver pied au mur les banlieux ont
besoin de tout sauf d'un improvisation
les événements de Grenoble si
grossièrement exploités devraient nous
servir d'avertissement les attentes sont
réelles les besoins criants la bonne
réponse n'est certainement pas de
multiplier les caméras de
vidéosurveillance mais d'avoir une
approche ambitieuse et globale cette
approche par passe par des moyens
humains et financiers conséquents pas
par un désengagement progressif
attendez-vous que les collectivités
territorial compense là encore votre
absence prolongée les collectivités
territoriales ne sont pas la variable
d'ajustement de vos errrances politiques
il revient à l'état de prendre ses
responsabilités il en va de même pour
les bailleurs sociaux ils ne doivent
nullement servir à exonérer l'état de
ses responsabilités monsieur le ministre
vous aviez prévu cette année de
ponctionner les organismes HLM pour
financer en partie l'en rue en d'autres
termes vous déhabillez Paul pour
habiller Pierre et vous prétendez que
cette mesure est liée à la volonté
gouvernementale de supprimer une niche
fiscale je ne peux que m'interroger sur
ce point depuis quand le fait de se
loger est-il devenu une niche fiscale
j'ai sendu d' manquer un épisode dans le
raisonnement fiscal je suis Cendant
rassuré en ce que les organismes HLM ont
également surpris sont également surpris
de cette déclaration nous sommes nous
sommes donc plusieurs à peinés à suivre
cette analyse en ponctionnant sans
vergogne les les bailleurs sociaux pour
financer l'en rue vous demandez donc aux
classes populaires qui vivent dans les
immeubl de financer les opérations de
rénovation et de réhabilitation les
concernant belle preuve de solidarité
nationale assurément le Sénat propose un
amendement à cette mesure qui revient à
un peu plus de réalis c'est un bon point
même si cela reste insuffisant la
politique de logement de ce gouvernement
est tout bonnement incompréhensible vous
êtes revenu sur le 1 % vous réduisez les
aides à la pierre de plus en plus
fortement et priver l'enrue de ces
moyens nous refusons le détricotage d'un
système au profit de la simple politique
d'accession à la propriété nous avons
besoin d'une politique ambitieuse pas
d'un budget indigent dépourvu de moyens
parce que vous refusez encore et
toujours de mettre àas ce bouclier
fiscal votre votre péché originel qui ni
l'impératif de solidarité nationale qui
est pourtant au cœur de notre pays pour
toutes les raisons vous aurez compris le
sens de notre vote je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Charles
Revet
madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues pourquoi
faire simple quand on peut faire
compliqué cette
formule s'il est un domaine où elle peut
s'appliquer monsieur le ministre du
Logement c'est bien celui dont vous avez
la responsabilité logement et urbanisme
le sujet mériterait un développement je
vais essayer de de l'expliquer dans les
quelques minutes qui me sont attribués
le logement représente un enjeu
extrêmement important tant au niveau
humain social qu'économique
humain car le logement est un des
éléments essentiels de la vie des
personnes et des familles social car le
contexte de l'habitat concourt
manifestement un bon équilibre de la
Société économique car de tout temps le
bâtiment à travers l'activité qu'il
génère est créateur d'emploi en grand
nombre et s'il est bien organisé de
manière durable C autre formule que
chacun peut avoir à l'esprit quand le
bâtiment va tout va l'illustre bien
notre pays a connu des années n faste
celle que l'on a appelé des tres
glorieuses et le bâtiment y a beaucoup
contribué tous les éléments monsieur le
ministre sont réunis aujourd'hui pour
que le bâtiment participe d'une manière
forte à un redémarrage économique le
besoin de logement est important il y a
manifestement des ensembles qui
justifient pour toutes sortes de raisons
d'une restructuration un nombre
important de familles rêv d'accéder la
propriété et le taux d'intérêt de
l'argent n'a jamais été aussi bas tous
les éléments sont donc
aujourd'hui réuni pour que le bâtiment
redevienne et pour de nombreuses années
un secteur d'activité dynamique et
développeur d'emploi alors me direz-vous
quel est le problème il est simple
rarement monsieur le ministre les
contraintes et les lourdeurs
administratives ont été aussi pesantes
rarement il a été aussi difficile de
faire aboutir un document d'urbanisme ou
pour les particuliers de faire sortir un
permis de construire la France est le
pays d'Europe qui dispose du plus grand
espace ce qui dev devrait faciliter la
construction de logement et plus
particulièrement le développement de
l'accession à la propriété c'est le
souhait d'un grand nombre de familles et
c'était me semble-t-il un objectif
prioritaire voulu par le Président de la
République la raréfaction des terrain
disponible et la conséquence qui en
découle sur le prix du foncier font en
sorte que la moitié des familles qui
pouvaient accéder à la propriété il y a
20 ou 30 ans encore ne le peuvent plus
aujourd'hui et surcoup que cela g amène
les organismes gestionnaires de
logements sociaux à solliciter les
concours financiers des collectivités
qui sont déjà confrontés à des problèmes
financiers toute ma vie d'élu j'ai
développé la construction de logement
locatifs ou en accession dans les années
70 il était possible pour une famille
d'accéder à la propriété sur un terrain
de 1000 m² pour moins de 100000 francs
il y a 15 20 ans il fallait 100000 €
pour la même opération
et aujourd'hui il faut la même somme
pour le seul terrain et tout cela dans
la même commune la rareté fait la
chireté tout cela est complètement
absurde lorsque l'on mesure les enjeux
qu'il y a derrière humains sociaux et
économique monsieur le ministre vous
avez entre les mains la possibilité de
renverser cette situation ce n'est pas
une question d'argent mais seulement de
réglementation et je veux ici vous faire
une suggestion toutes les villes et
communes de France qui justifient d'un
document d'urbanisme en sont doté faire
une révision classique équivaut en terme
de délis à ce qui est nécessaire à
l'élaboration d'un document initial sauf
dans quelques cas particulier la
structure de la commune n'a pas été
modifi qu'est-ce qui justifie de devoir
reprendre l'ensemble des éléments
préparatoires en terme d'état des li
diagnostic il faut entre trois délis
dans les meilleurs des cas plus souvent
5 ou 6 ans pour faire aboutir un projet
je suggère monsieur le ministre que
d'une manière dérogatoire à travers la
procédure de révision simplifié et en
élargissant les possibilités de
classement des espaces qu'elle offre les
communes qui le souhaitent puissent
dégager des terrains disponibles et les
ouvrir à la construction ce qui
permettrait d'augmenter l'offre de
foncier il ne s'agit pas de faire du
mitage comme trop souvent nous le met en
avant mais seulement de déverrouiller
une situation qui fait aujourd'hui
blocage peut-être ne serait-il pas
inutile monsieur le ministre que vous
disiez à vos services sur le terrain qui
aujourd'hui font preuve d'un Zè pour le
moins excessif qu'ils ont aussi une
mission de conseil d'accompagnement et
de facilitateur pour l'élaboration et le
cheminement des projets si nous allons
dans ce sens monsieur le ministre et la
décision est entre vos mains nous
pourrions outre la satisfaction que cela
apportera à de nombreuses familles
pouvoir redire quand le bâtiment va
tout va je vous remercie de votre
attention merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Jean
Desessard madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le secrétaire
d'État mon les rapporteur chers
collègues le gouvernement Fillon 2 a
promis la rigueur nous nous attendions
un budget austère c'est un budget
désolant un exemple le budget des
centres sociaux le constat est unanime
la précarité mine notre pays 8 millions
de Français dont 2 millions d'enfants
vivent aujourd'hui sous le seuil de
pauvreté partout en France le tissu des
centres sociaux lutte au quotidien
contre les exclusions pour maintenir ou
pour restaurer le lien social pour
favoriser l'insertion pour maintenir le
logement des plus démunis et permettre
aux gens de ne pas s'enfoncer davantage
pourtant vous nous proposez monsieurs
les ministres dans votre mission ville
et logement de réduire leur budget de 36
%. pour économiser 9 petits millions
d'euros et dans le même temps est-il
utile de le rappeler 1169 personnes
bénéficient de 400 23 millions d'euros
au titre de bouclier fiscal ce n'est pas
simplement du cynisme c'est aussi une
erreur une démocratie ne peut prospérer
durablement sur une fracture sociale or
ces 9 malheureux millions ce ne sont pas
des subsides pour assister ils font
vivre un réseau et pour un emploi
financé c'est plus d'une dizaine de
bénévoles qui apportent leur concours
voilà des effets leviers que vous ne
savez pas voir mais tant pis vous
persistez dans votre politique
suicidaire de réduction des dépenses
sans vouloir toucher à l'impôt
qu'importe le naufrage du corps social
tant qu'on entend jouer l'orchestre de
la RGPP en vain d'ailleurs puisque comme
l'ont relevé les rapporteur vous
sous-estimez chaque année les dépenses
pour ensuite rectifier les crédits et
pour la politique du logement vous
externalisez vous privatisez pour vous
rien ne serait échapper au marché le 14
septembre 2006 fier d'un récent voyage
aux États-Unis Nicolas Sarkozi
expliquait dans sa convention pour la
France d'après qu'il lui fallait une
France de propriétaire et que la recette
était simple il suffisait d'accorder des
crédits hypothécaires et d'assouplir les
règles prudentielles des banques on a vu
où cette politique nous a mené un fiasco
financier international
la majorité des ménages vivent en zone
urbaine consacre aujourd'hui entre 40 et
50 % de ses revenus au logement dont les
charges fixes incompressibles ne cessent
d'augmenter sur le marché libre les
loyers ont augmenté de 26 % 6 ans pas
une semaine ne passe sans que la presse
ne se fasse l'écho d'un nouveau record
de la bulle immobilière la raison
commanderait de détendre le marché
d'accroître l'ofre pour répondre à la
demande en un mot de construire et je
parle pas seulement du logement social
et pourtant 435000 logements construits
en 2007 368000 en 2008
333000 en 2009 et votre nouveau budget
entérine inexorablement la baisse et non
seulement les aides à la pierre
s'amenuise mais encore vous vous
défaussez du relica en ponctionnant les
opérateurs
HLM dans le même temps vous gaspillez
des milliards d'euros de dépenses
fiscales au mieux pas auou peu peu
utille comme les dispositifs borlau
deobien ou seller dont on peut observer
ici et là les immeubles à moitié vide au
pire à voocation spéculative comme la
mouture plus du prêt à taux zéro que
vous nous proposez cette année et que
dire des 14 milliards d'euros d'aide à
la personne mal employée puisqu'ils
amènent les propriétaires à augmenter
d'autant leurs exigences en l'absence de
tout encadrement de loyer quel gâie
des mesures doivent être prises encadrer
fermement les loyers réorienter les
dépenses fiscales vers la pierre
construire de vrais logements sociaux au
lieu de contourner la loi
SRU taxer les logements vacants de
manière dissuasive toiletter
soigneusement les règles d'attribution
et de conservation des logements sociaux
et puis l'actualité monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi d'évoquer le droit de
réquisition
étudiants été jugés au TGI de Paris ce
lundi après-midi pour l'occup de
l'immeuble vide depuis 10 ans de 69 ru
de Sèvre au cœur du 6e arrondissement
ces étudiants habitaient et entretenit
l'immeuble il s'était engagé à quitter
les lieux dès que la propriétaire vrait
louer vendre ou faire des travaux
celle-ci a préféré les harceler au
tribunal et leur demander 460000 €. je
vous avais soumis ce cas exemplaire
monsieur le secrétaire d'État par une
cré écrite en date du 9 juillet 2009 en
vous suggérant de diganter une
réquisition comme la loi le permet vous
nous aviez alors répondu que la
réquisition est une procédure complexe
et qu'il fallait mieux apâer la
propriétaire multimillionnaire
domiciliés fiscalement en Belgique par
des abattements fiscaux de 70 % sur les
recettes locatives et si vous défendez
bec et ongle le droit de propriété
fut-il abusif on ne peut pas en dire
autant du droit au logement puisque près
de 3 ans après l'entrée en vigueur de la
loi d'allau au moins 14000 familles
reconnu comme prioritaire n'ont toujours
rien vu venir en conclusion pour les
écologistes le logement n'est pas un
bien comme les autres c'est un droit un
rempart contre la précarité la
désocialisation l'exclusion du système
vous aurez compris messieur le ministre
que nous divergeion sensiblement et même
plus sur l'analyse de la situation du
logement en France et que votre
politique nous est intolérable en
conséquence nous ne vons pas les crédits
de cette mission je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Maurice Leroi ministre de la
Ville madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur soci spécial messieurs les
rapporteurs pour avis mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs permettez-moi
tout d'abord de vous dire tout l'honneur
que j'ai aujourd'hui d'être devant votre
Haute assemblée avec Benoît àaru quelle
meilleure manière que de commencer son
mandat de ministre de la Ville par
l'examen du budget alloué à cette
politique devant des élus fortement
impliqués sur le devenir de nos
quartiers permettez-moi de remercier
chaleureusement l'ensemble des
rapporteurs pour la qualité de leurs
travaux monsieur le rapporteur spécial
philippe Dallier messieurs les
rapporteurs pour avis jean-marievan
leurberg Thierry Repentin et
Pierre-André qui n'est certes pas avec
nous aujourd'hui et à qui je souhaite un
PR rétablissement mais qui a été
remarquablement remplacé par Dominique
braille que je remercie de son
soutien mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs comme l'a indiqué le premier
ministre dans sa déclaration de
politique génér
le gouvernement souhaite renforcer la
politique de la ville et lui donner une
nouvelle impulsion c'est la raison pour
laquelle le président de la République
et le Premier ministre ont souhaité
faire de la ville un ministère de plein
exercice à vocation
interministérielle c'est l'avenir de
notre pays qui se joue dans ces
territoires c'est un enjeu de
civilisation le rattachement du Grand
Paris à ce ministère traduit bien la
volonté du Président de la République et
du gouvernement de fédérer les énergies
pour répondre aux besoins immédiats des
habitants de l'île-de-fance et des
régions limitrophes pour préparer
l'avenir afin d'inventer un cadre de vie
harmonieux pour réconcilier l'urbain et
l'humain et gagner la bataille de
l'emploi au service de tous les Français
je veux ici saluer le travail accompli
par la secrétaire d'État chargée de la
politique de la ville fadellaa Amara
euh car je considère
qu'effectivement la politique de la
ville doit s'inscrire dans la durée et
je regrette que votre collègue Yv doge
n''est pas pu être présent ce soir car
je tenais à saluer celui qui dans votre
Haute Assemblée a été le premier délégué
interministériel à la ville et dont les
compétences sont reconnues mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ce budget
préserve nos principaux leviers
d'intervention tout en contribuant aux
efforts que nous devons tous consentir
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances pour rétablir l'équilibre
de nos finances publiques je sais que
vous y êtes très attaché personnellement
et je partage cette idée les efforts je
viens de le dire les efforts de la
nation en faveur des quartiers ne
peuvent se réduire au seul crédit du
programme sans 47 au 618 millions
d'euros du programme je le dis notamment
à madame barisa quiari on peut pas
réduire la politique de la ville comme
vous l'avez fait et vous le savez très
bien d'ailleurs au seul programme
147 puisque au 618 millions d'euros du
programme il convient de prendre en
compte les 310 millions d'euros de
dépenses fiscales au service du
développement économique et de l'emploi
mais aussi mais aussi les dotations de
péréquation la dotation de solidarité
urbaine qui représente près d'1,3
milliard d'euros et la dotation de
développement urbain à hauteur de 50
millions d'euros la rénovation urbaine
constitue un des piliers de la politique
de la ville et ainsi ont été engagés
monsieur le rapporteur Bray l'a dit près
de 12 milliards d'euros la politique de
la ville fait aussi appel au crédit de
droit commun environ 2 milliards d'euros
je souhaite mettre en œuvre dans les
prochaines semaines des expérimentations
sur une trentaine de quartiers
couvrant près de 300000 habitants pour
relancer la mobilisation des crédits de
droit commun dans ces contrats urbains
de cohésion sociale ça me tient très à
cœur je je je pense qu'on ne on
n'expérimente pas assez en France on
n'expérimente pas suffisamment président
de mon conseil général j'ai eu le
bonheur de d'expérimenter le revenu de
solidarité active et je pense que il
faut qu'on puisse faire ce type
d'expérimentation je tiens à dire à
Monsieur Jacques mzard à madame Odette
terade et à Madame Bariza quiari que si
les crédits du programme présentent une
baisse de 12 % c'est vrai vous avez
raison pardon vous avez tout simplement
omis je suis sûr que c'est un oubli mais
vous avez tout simplement omis de
rappeler que c'est parce que c'est la
loi c'est le respect de la loi c'est le
respect mécanique de l'application de la
loi puisque celle-ci est constituée à 60
% de la diminution prévu par la loi des
remboursements d'exonération des charges
sociales dans les zones franches
urbaines et dans les zones de
revitalisation urbaine il faut pas être
il faut le le rappeler en cet instant ma
priorité consiste donc vous l'aurez
compris à préserver les leviers d'action
sur le terrain au profit des territoires
et des population j'ajoute que dans le
cadre du budget trional les crédits
relatifs au CX devrait être stabilisé au
niveau de 2011 et je le confirme devant
votre Haute Assemblée c'est une
formation importante que je vous livre
et seront prolongé jusqu'en
2014 voilà pour
les orateurs et oratrices qui
souhaitaent savoir où on allait ainsi le
prolongement jusqu'à 2014 donne une
réelle visibilité à la aux acteurs de
terrain pour les prochaines années ce
qui constitue aujourd'hui le cœur de la
politique de la ville sera donc vous le
voyez préservé et renforcé j'en viens à
présent à la prolongation du programme
de rénovation
urbaine je pense d'abord à la rénovation
urbaine et au PNR rue lancé par mon ami
Jean-Louis borlot la capacité
d'affectation de l'enrue est désormais
de
16,621 milliards d'euros qui génère plus
de 42 milliards d'euros de travaux
programmé sur les 5 prochaines années et
et cela les rapporteurs de votre Haute
Assemblée l'ont relevé les projets de
rénovation urbaine porte sur 480
quartiers dont
464 font l'objet de convention signées
et de paiement accéléré
aujourd'hui et Benoît app paru le dira
bien mieux que moi aujourd'hui on
construit plus qu'on ne démolit et les
résultats sont visibles cette dynamique
se poursuit en 2010 pour autant et c'est
la raison la rançon du succès de notre
programme de rénovation nous sommes
entré dans ce qu'on appelle la bosse de
l'enrue philippe Dallier notamment le
relev avec un besoin plus grand de
financement du PNRU comme l'a d'ailleurs
souligné comme je le disais votre
Rapporteur spécial sur ce point le
gouvernement et en particulier benut
apparu vous a proposé une mesure de
péréquation sur les bailleurs sociaux
permettant d'absorber ce besoin
complémentaire de financement grâce au
travail déjà engagé par l'Assemblée
nationale nous sommes arrivés à un
dispositif dont la capacité de
péréquation est beaucoup plus importante
et permet de toucher principalement les
Dosu dormant c'est une mesure juste et
équilibrée dont l'intégralité du produit
retourne au secteur du logement social
en l'occurrence l'enrue et les aides à
la pierre
la notion de géographie prioritaire est
au cœur de la politique de la ville or
aujourd'hui et vous en conviendrait la
cartographie des zones urbaines
sensibles n'est plus adaptée comme l'a
rappelé le Premier ministre tout
récemment à garge
lesgonès petit rappel pour Monsieur
mzard c'était pas un cadeau de départ de
Madame Fadela Amara c'était le discours
du premier ministre à garge lgonè c'est
bien d'être précis une réflexion sera
engagée dès 2011 pour définir les
critères de sélection qui présideront la
future géographie de la politique de la
ville et qui permettront de concentrer
les crédits sur les quartiers qui en ont
le plus besoin mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs j'ai une conviction les
banlieux intégrés à la ville constituent
une chance pour la France et pas un
handicap elles sont pour moi synonyme de
richesse et de diversité culturelle
comme d'innovation la France de demain
se construira dans ces villes solidaire
je vous remercie de votre attention et
monsieur le Président de la
Commission et Monsieur président de la
commission des finances en ayant
respecté le temps de parole merci la
parole est à Monsieur Benoît Apparu
secrétaire d'État auprès de la ministre
de l'écologie du développement durable
des transports et du logement chargé du
logement
madame la la
présidente monsieur le Président
messieurs les rapporteurs Mesdames et
Messieurs les les sénateurs et les
sénatrices j'espère être aussi bref que
Maurice Leroi et je vais m'efforcer à
mon tour de respecter le temps de parole
pour
évidemment répondre à à la demande du
président trois mots peut-être sur le le
budget trois sujets principaux
dans ce programme logement un nous avons
souhaité dans le cadre du programme
177 obtenir ce qu'on appelle le rebasage
budgétaire c'est-à-dire avoir enfin une
loi de finance la plus crédible possible
en début d'année vous savez tous comment
ça marche depuis 15 ans on a une loi de
finance initiale qui n'est pas sincère
et on a en cours d'année deux ou trois
décrets d'avance pour abonder les
crédits c'est ce qui se passe depuis 15
ans c'est d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé
également cette année nous avons obtenu
pour 2011 d'avoir une vraie sincérité
budgétaire dès le début de l'année sur
le programme 177 nous permettant
ainsi de pouvoir contractualiser avec
les associations dans le cadre de
contrat de performance d'objectifs et de
moyens nous permettant là encore de
donner de la sécurité et de la
visibilité au monde associatif et je
souhaitais souligner ce point deuxème
fait notable de ce budget bien bien
évidemment le nouveau préatoau zéro j'y
reviendrai dans dans quelques instants
c'est évidemment la réponse à
l'engagement du président de la
République de développer la France de
propriétaire troisième élément il a été
évoqué à plusieurs reprises nous y
reviendront également dans le cadre de
la discussion des amendements la
péréquation que nous proposons à la
haute assemblée qui a été fortement
modifiée à l'Assemblée nationale j'ai
cru comprendre qu'il y avait des des
amendements non négligeables sur le
sujet nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
tout à l'heure mais je voudrais surtout
essayer de répondre à différentes
interventions
euh des sénateurs et des sénatrices tout
d'abord monsieur le rapporteur d'allier
vous dire que sur l'aide alimentaire que
vous estimez
sous-évaluer un amendement sera discuté
vous l'avez signalé tout à l'heure qui
permettra de compenser la baisse sur le
PEAD qui est le programme EUR européen
il y a une baisse de 6 millions et on
abande on on abande pardon de 9 millions
d'euros le budget mais vous l'avez
signalé tout à l'heure vous avez raison
sur l'absence de données statistiques
concernant le
celllier nous n'avons pas la répartition
géographique précise il nous faudra en
la matière
demander des obligations particulières
aux producteurs afin d'avoir les retours
d'information que vous demandez je
partage votre analyse sur ce sujet
monsieur Repentin nous reviend je pense
dans la
discussion des amendements sur bien
évidemment ce que vous appelez le
désengagement de l'État en matière de
logement social je me bornerai là encore
à répéter les chiffres que vous
connaissez aussi bien que moi mais entre
1978 et 2003 droite gauche confondu hein
on est bien d'accord sur la période
c'est 50000 logements sociaux financés
en moyenne depuis le plan de cohéson
social initié par Jean-Louis borlot
c'est 100000 par an en moyenne avec une
pointe à 120000 l'année dernière et la
même chose cette année alors je veux
bien qu'on parle de desengagements de
l'État mais quand on double la
production il me semble que c'est plutôt
une politique positive de la part de
l'État et de l'ensemble des partenaires
et de grâce peut-être essayons d'éviter
cette approche peut-être un peu
maniquenne qui consiste à dire que tout
ce qui va bien c'est les collectivités
locales et le monde HLM et tout ce qui
va mal c'est l'état c'est peut-être un
peu simplificateur et je souhaiterais si
vous le voulez bien que l'on a accepte
les uns et les autres que cet effort de
construction de logements sociaux c'est
un effort des collectivités locales
c'est un effort des bailleurs sociaux
c'est également un effort important de
l'État monsieur le le le rapporteur
concernant le PTZ+
universel je voudrais expliquer pourquoi
nous avons fait le choix de
l'universalité pour raison très simple
c'est quand vous regardez les déciles de
revenus correspondant à ce prêt à tau zé
universel nous avons effectivement
ouvert au dcil 9 et 10 quand l'ancien
PTZ se limitait enfin sarrêtter au dcil
8 il faut simplement regarder le niveau
de revenu auquel correspond les desciles
9 et 10 le descil 9 en zone C pour
quelqu'un de célibataire commence à 1500
€ 1500 € par mois et le descile 9
commence lui à 2200 € par mois je ne
suis pas convaincu qu'on puisse
considérer que ces gens-là sont des gens
extrêmement riche si on prend la zone A
le dcil 9 et le DC le dcil 8 pardon et
le non le 9 et le 10 excusez-moi doivent
commencer l'un à 2500 € et l'autre à
3200 €. là encore il s'agit de classe
moyenne et non pas de personnes riches
pourquoi tout simplement parce que
quelqu'un qui est déjà fortuné comme
vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure il n'est
pas primo acccédent il n'est plus primo
accident il est déjà propriétaire il n'a
donc pas droit pas accès au prê à tau
zéro donc l'univers ité c'est clairement
une possibilité qui est offerte
notamment aux classes moyenne d'accéder
à la propriété je me répète 1500 € de
revenus pour un célibataire en zone C ce
n'est pas me semble-t-il quelqu'un de
riche qui dev qui pourrait accéder à la
propriété sans être aidé je vous rejoins
sur la GRL c'est un dispositif là encore
initié par par Jean-Louis borlot c'est
un je crois excellent dispositif qui n'a
pas encore trouvé
totalement sa cible
notamment parce que nous avons encore
des désaccords avec les assureurs mais
nous le nous évoquerons ce sujet tout à
l'heure monsieur mard juste un mot
concernant là encore le prê àau zéro
nous l'avons évoqué à plusieurs reprises
je veux bien qu'on parle de
désengagement de l'État là encore pour
la zone C mais quand les montants
financiers de l'État pour la zone C
passent de 600 millions d'euros à 800
millions d'euros je vois pas où il y a
un désengagement de l'État 200 millions
d'euros de plus pour la zone C pour les
territoires ruraux c'est au contraire la
reconnaissance par l'État de
l'importance de l'accession à la
propriété en zone en zone C je
reviendrai tout à l'heure dans le cadre
du débat sur la péréquation sur
différentes interventions je pense
évidemment à celle d'Alain Foucher de
pierre
Jarlier ou à à Jean de cessard et al non
al c'est pas n'est pas intervenu
finalement et je terminerai mon mon
propos en quelques secondes sur euh deux
interventions C de pierre Jarlier et
Charles de Charles Revet euh il y a une
inquiétude sur la zone C vous l'avez
évoqué concernant les aides à la pierre
en zone C euh là encore le message que
souhaite passer l'État c'est de dire il
faut accentuer la production là où c'est
nécessaire parce que nousons nous notons
aujourd'hui un déséquilibre en sens
inverse on produit plus aujourd'hui en
zone B2 et en zone C qu'en zone A et B1
ce que l'on souhaite c'est rééquilibrer
là où c'est véritablement nécessaire ce
qui ne veut surtout pas dire qu'on va
supprimer la production de logement
sociaux en zone C aujourd'hui on produit
25 % zone C 25 % zone a peut-être qu'il
faut juste rééquilibrer les choses au
bénéfice du a et en faire effectivement
un peu moins en C mais nous continuerons
à produire des logements sociaux en zone
C bien évidemment enfin Charles Revet a
eu un long propos sur l'urbanisme vous
savez que c'est la priorité du président
de la République il l'a réaffirmé il y a
quelques quelques jours en souhaitant
que nous simplifions l'urbanisme parce
que je partage et nous partageons tous
votre analyse les procédures actuelles
sont trop complexes trop longues donc
trop coûteuses pour l'ensemble de ceux
qui souhaitent bâtir des logements qui
souhaitent porter des projets et nous
allons là encore nous consacrer pendant
l'année 2011 à simplifier le droit de
l'urbanisme pour que la dynamique de
projet emporte sur la dynamique des
normes voilà les quelques éléments de
réponse que je souhaitais formuler en
attendant évidemment le débat sur les
amendements merci à tous merci monsieur
le
ministre nous allons procéder à l'examen
des amendements portant sur les crédits
de la mission ville et logements
figurant à l'état B
je monsieur le Président de la
Commission des des finances madame la
Présidente je souhaiterais que l'on
appelle en
priorité l'article attaché
98 sur lequel la commission des finances
a va proposer au Sénat un
amendement quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le ministre quel
est l'avis du Gouvernement sur la
proposition euh avis favorable sur
l'appel en priorité
ordonn bien nous passons donc à cet
article 98 avec une demande de parole de
Madame
terade courte madame la la présidente
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le présentarticle TS à
augmenter de 04 à 05 la contribution
patronale au Fond national d'aide au
logement final ass 6e donc sur la masse
salariale si cet article n'est pas
contestable en soi nous déplorons qu'il
permette une nouvelle fois comme on
témoigne l'amendement du rapporteur de
traduire un désengagement de l'État même
si le ministre n'est pas d'accord avec
cette appréciation ainsi le rapport de
la commission des finances le produit
supplémentaire attendu de cette
augmentation de taux évalué à 86
millions d'euros doit limiter à du
concurrence la subvention d'équilibre
versé par l'État au FNAL cette tendance
de la loi de finance 2011 se retrouve
dans l'ensemble des missions nous
assistons à une multiplication des
ressources extra buudgétaires qui visent
simplement à justifier donc ce
désengagement de l'État pour notre part
nous estimons que l'État doit maintenir
sa participation au Fond national d'aide
au logement qui finance la p et laals en
effet alors que la crise économique et
sociale a des conséquences
particulièrement graves sur les ménages
nous pouvons craindre que les
dispositifs d'APL et d'aide au logement
donc soi très sollicités cette année
encore et à ce titre nous vous alertons
une nouvelle fois sur l'inepsie de
baisser de 1,6 % les crédits du
programme d' d'aide à l'accès au
logement cette année pour toutes ces
raisons donc nous nous abstiendrons sur
cet article madame la Présidente merci
Madame TER
le je passe à l'amendement que défend
monsieur Dalier c'est l'amendement 26
merci Madame la la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues avant de
vous présenter cet amendement je
voudrais rappeler que les trois
amendements que la commission des
finances va vous présenter font en fait
partie d'un package si vous me permettez
le terme ou d'une solution globale que
la commission des finances a commencé à
vous présenter en première partie de
l'examen du projet de loi de finances en
effet la commission des finances a
souhaité proposer une solution qui
permettrait de sortir de la situation
quelque peu difficile dans laquelle nous
sommes à partir de la proposition du
gouvernement qui à l'été avait envisagé
effectivement de prélever 340 millions
d'euros sur les organismes achlem pour
financer l'enrue à hauteur de 260
millions et les aides à la pierre à
hauteur de 80 millions au travers d'un
fond de concours qui remonterait dans le
budget de l'État ce ce ces 340 millions
étit au départ assis sur une
contribution sur les revenus locatifs
alors qu'elle nous était présenté comme
un mécanisme de péréquation nous avons
donc considéré que ça n'était pas un
mécanisme de péréquation et nous avons
souhaité proposer au Parlement une autre
solution cette solution elle est
composée de trois parties la première
partie vous a été proposée donc par
Philippe Marini notre rapporteur général
et elle a visé à trouver les somme
nécessairire la plus grande partie des
sommes nécessaires à l'anrue pour passer
dans les 3 années à venir la fameuse
bosse de l'anrue puisque je vous
rappelle que l'agence aura besoin
d'environ 1 Millard 300 millions d'euros
de crédit de paiement et que les sommes
amenées pendant les trois prochaines
années par Action Logement ne seront pas
suffisantes et qu'il faut donc trouver
un complément de financement ce
complément de financement et le Sénat l'
adopté nous avons effectivement proposé
que ça soit au travers d'un prélèvement
effectué sur les nouvelles taxes qui
vont alimenter la société pour le Grand
Paris que nous les trouvions à hauteur
de 200 millions alors cette proposition
a été actée par le Sénat il nous reste
donc à trouver environ 50 à 60 millions
pour boucler l'enveloppe de 260 millions
à destination de l'anrue ça c'est
quelque part le premier étage de la
fusée que notre rapporteur général a
allumé si je puis dire au moment de
l'examen de la première partie les deux
autres étages de la fumée et le Sénat a
approuvé
les deux autres étages de la fusée euh
que dont nous allons discuter et qui
vous sont ici présenté vise
effectivement à compléter cet apport de
200 millions sur les taxes à destination
du Grand Paris à hauteur d'environ 50
million par l'amendement sur l'article
98 et puis sur l'article 99 nous vous
proposerons effectivement une solution
pour faire en sorte de trouver les 80
millions d'euros sur les aides à la
pierre au travers d'un véritable
mécanisme de péréquation entre les
bailleurs sociaux voilà mes chers
collègues le préambule que je souhaitais
posé parce que c'est bien une solution
globale que la commission des finances
vous a proposé ce qui suppose donc
puisque nous avons adopté la première
partie de cette solution et bien que
nous adoptions les parties suivantes
afin de poursuivre jusqu'en CMP
messieurs les ministre et je n'en doute
pas la discussion qui nous permettra de
trouver la meilleure
solution cher collègue quel est sur le
alors madame la Présidente sur l'article
98 et l'amendement qui vous êtes ici
proposé il s'agit en effet de soumettre
à la cotisation au finnal les employeurs
relevants du régime agricole qui
jusqu'alors n'y était pas soumis on peut
tout à fait considérer qu'il s'agissa
qu'il s'agissait là d'une niche fiscale
et qu'il convient de la supprimer
considérant que les salariés de ces
entreprises bénéficient des aides
personnelles au logement il n'y a pas de
raison particulière qu'elle ne soit pas
soumise à la cotisation au final voilà
pourquoi nous vous proposons cet
amendement qui devrait rapporter 53
millions
d'euros l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur
le ministre
oui madame la la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les les sénateur un avis
défavorable du gouvernement
euh je vais pas refaire le débat
d'ensemble mais sur la fusée à trois
étages préconisé par la commission des
finances le gouvernement a déjàis émis
pardon un avis défavorable sur le
premier étage et donc sur le 2e et le 3e
nous serons je mais je ne dis pas le
contraire et le gouvernement bien
évidemment on accepte l'augure
simplement lui aussi étant cohérent il
défend bien évidemment jusqu'au bout son
positionnement et notamment sur cet
amendement j'avoue que euh faire payer
au monde agricole l'en rue est un résumé
euh certes peut-être un peu facile de ma
part monsieur le rapporteur il n'en
demeure pas moins que en gros on va dans
une période je crois difficile pour le
monde agricole aujourd'hui même si on
est bien d'accord qu'il s'agit là des
coopératives agricoes de plus de 20
salariés il n'en demeure pas moins que
le monde agricole traverse aujourd'hui
une crise sans précédent et qu'augmenter
euh les cotisations employeurs c'est
alourdir les charges qui pèsent sur le
travail dans le monde agricole je ne
crois pas au regard de la crise agricole
que nous traversons que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui que ce soit le signe le plus
le plus
judicieux à apporter au monde agricole
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
Gouvernement est défavorable sur le
mécanisme qui est trouvé pour l'instant
par votre rapporteur mais qui plus est
là plus encore sur cette deuxème étage
de fusée parce que je me répète cert je
l'entends bien dans un résumé un peu
facile mais l'enrue et le monde agricole
le lien n'est pas tout à fait évident à
trouver et je me répète surtout
aujourd'hui vu la crise que traverse le
monde agricole je ne suis pas convaincu
de la nécessité d'augmenter le coût du
travail en la matière monsieur le
président de la commission des
finances monsieur le
ministre ce n'est pas une construction
facile que
celle du financement de
l'anrue c'est c'est un magnifique projet
mais qui jusqu'à maintenant n'a pas
vraiment trouvé son financement et nous
sommes appelés les uns et les autres à
un effort d'imagination et et
d'abnégation
euh vous avez compris
que le Sénat par souci de cohérence est
invité à aller jusqu'au bout de sa
démarche nous avons voté le premier
pilier le le premier étage de la fusée
nous pouvons pas nous arrêter en chemin
euh
c'est une première donnée sur le taux de
cotisation de la
Fenal j'avoue que c'est toujours très
délicat d'augmenter les cotisations
sociales car à l'heure de la
mondialisation c'est prendre le risque
d'accroître le coût du travail et
d'activer un peu plus les phénomènes de
délocalisation je ferme cette parenthèse
et et nous sommes prêts à consentir cet
effort mais parmi les contributeurs il y
aura aussi les collectivités
territoriales et qui vont
être sollicité à hauteur de 80 millions
à peu près j'entends bien votre argument
sur les coopératives agricoles et le
monde agricole mais parmi les
entreprises qui sont au service du monde
agricole il n'y a pas que des
coopératives il y a un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui sont soumises aux
impositions de droit commun et qui ell
participe à ce
financement il m'arrive de penser que
quelquefois les coopératives ont des
superstructures qui qui n'ont pas
toujours démontré d'ailleurs euh leur
pleine efficacité on pourrait trouver de
nombreux exemples quelquefois
la
structure capte certains des avantages
consentis au coopératifs sans que les
agriculteurs au nom desquels ces
avantages sont
consentis trouvent directement le
bénéfice
attendu donc dans ces conditions euh je
pense que ça n'est pas faire offense euh
aux règles même d'une concurrence
loyale que de faire disparaître cette
niche
sociale et puis il peut arriver aussi
que des salariés du monde
agricole trouvve à se loger dans des
structures urbaines ou
périurbaines qui sans doute font partie
des opérations couvertes par l'en
rue
h merci est-ce qu'il y a des d'autres
des explications de
vote alors je fais voter sur
l'amendement qui a été présenté par
Monsieur
Dalier ceux qui sont favorables à son
adoption vousoudre bien lever la
main ceux son sont
contre
abstentionbien l'amendement est
adopté je fais voter sur l'article
98 ceux qui sont favorables à l'adoption
de l'article 98 le manifesteront en
levant la main
l'article
98 ceux qui sont contre
abstention il est adopté l'article est
adopté nous passons à l'article 48
l'Étap B avec l'amendement 28 que
présente également monsieur
Dalier merci madame la Présidente
monsieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre il n'y a
effectivement aucun lien entre les
cotisations au final du monde agricole
et l'en rue mais nous avons le souci de
ne pas dégrader le sold budgettaire je
pense que vous devriez être sensible
voilà pourquoi si effectivement nous
proposons de réduire de 53 millions ici
les aides à l'accès au logement donc la
contribution au final pour les
réaffecter à la politique de la ville et
contribuer ainsi au financement de l'EN
rue il nous fallait bien préalablement
nous assurer que le FNAL bénéficierait
des crédits qui lui sont nécessaires
donc je je ferme cette parenthèse donc
cet amendement vise effectivement à
abonder les crédits sign à la politique
de la ville pour le financement de lrue
à hauteur de 53 millions si l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le ministre par
souci de cohérence avec l'amendement
précédent avis desfab bien
évidemment je considère que c'est le
même vote que tout tout à
l'heure l'amendement 151 monsieur
braille
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues donc cet
amendement s'inscrit en cohérence totale
avec l'amendement de la commission des
finances qui vise à affecter donc les 53
millions de crédits au programme 109 au
programme 146 pour financer la rue bon
je vous passerai effectivement les les
transferts d'une opération et d'un
article à l'autre je voudrais simplement
dire que l'objectif est d'amander la
dotation de 10 millions d'euros qui est
inscrite pour financer les astreintes de
l'État qui est condamné à payer quand il
est dans l'incapacité de loger les
demandeurs de logement au ou
d'hébergement prioritaire au titre du
Dallot à et qui est à hauteur de 6
millions d'euros en effet le souci de
sincérité budgétaire auquel je crois
nous sommes tous attaché doit conture à
réviser le montant de cette dotation
pour le porter à 16 millions d'euros ce
montant correspond mieux à
l'appréciation des condamnations qui
pourrait être prononcé en 2011 par les
tribunaux voilà l'objet de cet
amendement l'avis de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur la présidente à partir du
moment où l'amendement précédent a été
adopté et bien je pense que nous pouvons
donner satisfaction à notre collègue
braay ce rebasage de 6 millions est
effectivement probablement nécessaire
l'avis du
Gouvernement je fais voter sur cet
amendement qui a recueilli un avis
favorable de la commission et du
gouvernement quels sont les avis
favorables contre il est
adopté trois amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le amendement
97 présente Monsieur Je monsieur
jeanerau merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues vous savez que depuis
1975 l'état très fidèlement apporte son
soutien au réseau que
représente l'Association nationale
d'information sur le logement et les
associations départementales
d'information sur le logement or la
dotation
envisagé au titre de ce budget
2011 conduirait à une réduction très
significative or une telle réduction des
dépenses de
fonctionnement pénaliserait très
fortement ces associations qui je le
rappelle ici exercent une mission de de
service public très importante vis-à-vis
des usagers en en particulier C ceux qui
sont à revenus modestes il informe sur
les conditions d'accès au logement les
droits et devoirs réciproques du
locataire du propriétaire et aussi sur
l'accès à la propriété ou toute question
touchant à l'amélioration de l'habitat
vous savez aussi que ces informations
sont données dans la neutralité et la
compétence professionnelle nécessaire
ainsi qu'à titre gratuit l'amendement
que nous vous proposons vise tout
simplement à pouvoir maintenir les
moyens de fonctionnement de laanil et
des AD
et je vous propose de prélever 1 million
d'euros sur l'action 05 soutien du
programme
135 afin d'abonder les crédits du
programme 109 aide à l'accès au logement
je vous remercie monsieur braille le
l'amendement 150 amendement identique
oui madame la Présidente effectivement
l'amendement a été présenté par notre
collègue Jean rau et la seule chose que
je voudais dire c'est que tous les
collègues ici présents et qui s'occupent
du logement et qui sont territorialement
basés connaissent les actions accessiv
positif que font les adiles dans leur
département et toujours en direction des
personnes les plus modestes donc les
arguments seraient les mêmes c'est donc
le même chose effectivement que présente
mon amendement merci l'amendement 162
monsieur
magrass merci madame la présidente
Madame la présidenteadame monsieur les
ministrre l'amendement est
défendu merci je je demande l'avis de la
commission merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur écoutez la Commission
souhaiterait connaître l'avis du
gouvernement parce que si effectivement
nous reconnaissons le travail de laanil
et les adiles s'il est effectivement
prévu de créer deux adiles
supplémentaires en 2011 cet abondement
d'un million d'euros des crédits nous
semble relativement important puisque
les crédits de laanille et de laadille
étaient de 7002 en 2010 et 695 en 2011
donc abonderz ces crédits d'un million
d'euros ça nous semble une somme très
importante alors peut-être il y a-t-il
une justification qui nous échappe
peut-être pourrons-nous pourrions-nous
rectifier à la baisse cette proposition
l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre ou Madame la la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs euh
un avis favorable du Gouvernement sur
cet amendement vous l'avez évoqué un le
maintien des crédits de la Nil au niveau
national d'une année sur l'autre premier
élément qui justifie cet amendement la
création de deux euh Adil dans donc dans
deux départements qui justifient des
compléments de crédit donc l'ensemble à
hauteur de de 500000 € les 500000 €
restants étant sur succession entre
guillemets d'autres associations voilà
la raison pour laquelle il y avait un
avis favorable du Gouvernement
maintenant votre proposition de
rectification si vous le
souhaitez ne rebaser entre guillemets
que sur les besoins particuli de la
nille le gouvernement il sera favorable
également
bien monsieur le
rapporteur on pourrait peut-être
rectifier à 500000 € parce que en
ajoutant 500000 € effectivement on règle
le problème de la Nil de la création des
deux mais écoutez je pense que on serait
sur une augmentation qui qui
avoisinerait les 15 % en cette période
difficile bon peut quand même
s'interroger sur le bien fondé de la
demande moi je pense que nous pourrions
couper la poire en 2 et proposer
effectivement un abondement à 500000
€ qu l'avis de des
autres auteurs d'amendement monsieur
braay j'avoue que la démonstration de
notre collègue philippe Dallier
effectivement me paraît tout à fait
raisonnable en pas personnellement je me
ramènerai à la proposition faite par le
représentant de la Commission des
finances monsieur magr même bien
monsieur le monsieur le président de la
commission des
finances je crois que c'est c'est une
démarches constructive et c'est aussi un
encouragement à la mutualisation car je
vois dans les départements se multiplier
les guichets d'information et si toute
cette toutes ces structures pouvaient se
rassembler je pense que ce pourrait être
un facteur
d'économie monsieur
jeanerau bien
écoutez j'entends les arguments qui qui
ont été donnés je voudrais simplement
indiquer à monsieur le Président de la
Commission des des finances vous savez
que les départements contribuent au
financement de de ces adiles et de
manière très significative et dans le
contexte les départements je
n'apprendrai rien à personne ici sont
conduits pour des raisons que vous
connaissez à contenir très strictement
leur budget et il me paraissait pas tout
à fait scandaleux dans le contexte que
effectivement sans que le budget
sollicité soit soit dispensieux que nous
puissions ça équilibrait les comptes
arrondir à ce million d'euros et ça nous
permettait d'assurer le développement
dans un contexte qui encore une fois
vous le savez est très difficile
notamment pour les publics qui
fréquentent aujourd'hui le réseau des
adiles et encore une fois dans un
contexte de fort restriction pour les
départements et je me fais la
l'interprète aussi des départements de
France merci il y a pas d'autres Inter
tion je vais faire voter sur
l'amendement présenté par Monsieur
jeanerauon rectifieré l'amendement 97
rectifié 1 million 1 Milon 1 million 1
million ou je fais voter sur monsieur le
Président la Commission des
finances sur 1 million la commission est
défavorable et et sera lira euh à
l'amendement de Monsieur braille
rectifié le 150
rectifié portant cet ajustement à 500000
€
mon bien alors l'amendement je
l'amendement jeanerau je fais voter sur
l'amendement
jeanerau ceux qui sont favorables à
l'adoption
ceux qui sont
contre il n'est pas adoptéant les
maintenant l'amendement de Monsieur
braille et de Monsieur
magrass
rectifié à 500000 ce qui sont favorables
à
l'adoption ceux qui sont contre ils sont
adopté le l'amendement 2 du gouvernement
oui madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les les sénateurs euh je l'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure le gouvernement
souhaite une vraie sincérité budgétaire
sur le programme 177 c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous vous présentons cette
amendement une vraie sincérité
budgétaire c'est vrai que c'est un peu
redondant je l'admets volontiers avec
deux points sur cet amendement
s'agissant de l'aide alimentaire 9,3
million d'euros s'ajoutant au 13
millions déjà prévus pour compenser la
baisse européenne en la matière et
s'agissant des pensions de famille
système que nous développons que nous
développons pardon comme alternative à
l'hébergement dans le cadre de l'accès
au logement 8 million d'euros
supplémentaires pour accompagner la
montée en charge de ce dispositif l'avis
la commission monsieur le rapporteur il
est bien évidemment favorable madame la
Présidente en souhaitant effectivement
monsieur le ministre que nous ne soyons
pas obligés d'y revenir en cours d'année
2011 s'il n'y a pas d'explication de
vote je vais voter sur cet amendement
qui a recueilli un avis favorable et de
la Commission et du
gouvernement la l'avis favorable vous
levez la main ceux qui sont
d'accord ceux qui sont
contre il est adopté le 29 monsieur
daller madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres je m'empresse de dire que cet
amendement je le dis pour Charles Revet
est un amendement d'appel qui visait à a
supprimé les crédits inscrits au titre
de la subvention pour charge de service
public versé à l'institut de formation
aux carrières administrative sanitaire
et social de dieep dans le attachement à
la présente mission ville et logement
nous semblait pour le moins un peu
surprenant alors les crédits qui sont
ici inscrits ont déjà été divisés par
deux par ceux par rapport à ceux qui
étaient inscrits l'année dernière signe
évidemment que le gouvernement
s'interroge ceci étant dit est-ce qu'il
ne faut pas aller au bout de la logique
et inscrire ses crédits ailleurs parce
que je vois pas très bien comment cet
institut pourra fonctionner avec la
moitié de ses crédits est-ce que vous
pourriez monsieur le ministre nous en
dire un peu
plus monsieur le
ministre je je peux le faire monsieur le
le rapporteur je peux vous en dire un
peu plus sur l'cass l'ifcf c'est quoi
c'est la formation carrière
administrative sanitaire et sociale
située à diep et qui en fait accueille
essentiellement des stagiaires en
provenance de
l'outreem
réflexion actuelle sur le devenir de
l'ifcas c'est la raison pour le
gouvernement vous propose de diviser par
de la subvention qui permettra à
l'IFCASS d'assurer la saison
2010-21 donc non enfin l'année scolaire
si vous voulez 2010-211 sera assurée
avec la moitié de la subvention puisque
nous aurons qu'une moitié d'année
budgétaire la partie 2011 de la année
scolaire en question et le gouvernement
engage une réflexion sur l'année 2011
sur le devenir de l'IFCASS non pas sur
la nécessité des formations notamment
pour les stagiaires outrem et pour
savoir comment mieux mutualiser pour
reprendre l'expression du président à
l'instant sur l'ensemble des autres
instituts similaires existant dans le
pays si nous considérons courant de
l'année
2011 que nous devons perpétuer cette
ificace là à ce moment-là nous
reviendrons de devant vous pour demander
les crédits supplémentaires mais si
comme il est probable possible il y a
l'évolution que j'indiquais tout à
l'heure nous n'aurons pas besoin d'y
revenir et à ce moment-là la subvention
s'éteindra l'année prochaine quand on
rattachement effectivement de ces
crédits au logement ça fait partie des
mystères budgétaires que j'imagine les
uns et les autres nous sommes incapables
de découvrir l'origine monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
Ret
monsieur le ministre
entend imprimer une vraie sincérité
budgétaire je pense que vous pourriez
accueillir avec bienveillance cet
amendement et votre collègue chargé de
l'outreem pourrait proposer un
amendement du même montant pour que ces
crédits apparaissent non pas dans la
mission ville et logement mais dans la
mission
outreem
monsieur le
ministre j'entends bien que dans le
casadre de la vraie sincérité budgétaire
véritable il serait
judicieux de procéder ainsi moi ce que
je vous propose si vous le voulez bien
ces crédits sont inscrits sur ce budget
là depuis un grand nombre d'années nous
avons une réflexion en cours certes ce
n'est pas une raison je vous propose
plutôt le retrait ou le rejet de cet
amendement puisque nous allons régler la
question très rapidement dans le cadre
de la réflexion que j'évoé tout
alors le la monsieur daliier tiré madame
la Présidente
merci nous allons procéder au vote des
crédits de la mission ville et logement
figurant à l'étape B je n'ai été saisi
d'aucune demande d'explication de vote
avant l'expéd avant l'expiration du
délai limite je mets au voix les crédits
de la mission ceux qui sont favorables à
l'adoption de des crédits de la mission
ceux qui sont contre abstention
ils sont adoptés à l'article 99 une
demande de parole de Monsieur
Repentin madame la Présidente messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
l'article 99 du projet loi finance a
suscité comme vous le savez un vif et
moi au cours des derniers mois au sein
du monde HLM le dispositif en effet
initial était clairement inacceptable il
consistait en l'assugjétissement des
organismes HLM à la contribution sur les
revenus locatifs le produit de cette
contribution estimé à environ 350
millions d'euros pendant 3 ans devait
financer les aides à la pierre et la
rénovation urbaine contrairement à la
présentation je cite abusive et
trompeuse pour reprendre les termes du
rapport de la commission des finances
fait par le gouvernement il ne
s'agissait nullement d'un dispositif de
péréquation au sein du secteur du
logement social mais simplement
d'assurer le financement de l'enrue par
ailleurs la ponction de 340 millions
d'euros sur sur la trésorerie des
organisationlm pouvait conduire à
freiner la construction de logements
sociaux sur la base des données figurant
dans le rapport évaluant l'efficacité
des dépenses fiscales en faveur du
développement et l'amélioration de
l'offre de logement annexé au projet de
loi de finance on peut estimer qu'une
telle ponction aurait conduit à la non
construction d'environ
28500 logements par an du fait de la
mobilisation du mondehlem et des
réticences exprimées par les élus de
tout bord l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
un dispositif alternatif qui s'abu sur
le prélèvement pour insuffisance
d'investissement la célèbre taxe sur les
dos du Dormand imaginz au moment de la
loi molle dite aussi loi Boutin en 2009
ce dispositif n'est cependant pas
satisfaisant en effet 70 % des
organismes HLM seraient concerné par ce
dispositif d'après les chiffres que vous
avez évoqué monsieur le ministre lors
des débats à l'Assemblée nationale mais
peut-on sérieusement imaginer que 60 %
des organismes HLM sont des DOD duormand
disposant de trésoreries abordantes
deuxème point il ne s'agit toujours pas
d'un mécanisme de péréquation le
prélèvement finance toujours l'en rue
alors que comme l'indique notre
commission des finances je cite le
comblement du déficit de financement des
opérations de rénovation urbaine ne doit
pas être REM à la charge des bailleurs
sociaux mais relève du budget général de
l'État enfin le produit du prélèvement
n'atteignant que 260 millions d'euros le
reste est prélevé sur la caisse de
garantie du logement locatif social ce
qui est inaccepttable et remet
d'ailleurs en cause une des mesures de
la loi Boutin visiblement la commission
des finances du Sénat a beaucoup
travaillé sur cette question sous
l'action coordonnée du rapporteur
spécial philippe Dallier et du
rapporteur général Philippe Marini la
semaine dernière le Sénat a adopté un
dispositif assurant le financement de
l'enrue pour la période 201122 2013
l'amendement déposé par la commission
des finances à l'article 99 constitue
donc le deuxème volet de ce dispositif
alternatif cet amendement comprend
plusieurs avancées le prélèvement sur
les organismes HLM est réduit à 150
Milon d'euros l'assiette du prélèvement
est précisée et les subventions à
recevoir doivent en être exclus la
ponction réalisée sur la cgls est
supprimé et l'aspect peréquateur se
traduit par 150 millions d'euros qui
viendrait abonder la ligne fongible le
dispositif qui va nous être proposé et
donc si vous me permettez l'expression
moins pire que le dispositif adopté par
nos collègues députés et plus encore que
le dispositif initial inventé par le
gouvernement pour autant je regrette que
les organismesl soit ainsi mis à
contribution d'une part d'autres
ressources auraient pu être mobilisé je
note ainsi que l'article 56 du projet de
loi de finance prévoit la mise en place
d'un nouveau pré àau zéro le PTZ+ dont
l'universalité devrait coûter 80
millions d'euros en 2011 pour une
efficacité douteuse d'autre part ce
dispositif s'inscrit dans une logique je
le dis de désengagement de l'État en
matière de logement après Action
Logement qui a été mobilisé pour
financer l'en rue les bailleurs sociaux
sont maintenant mobilisés pour compenser
la diminution des aides budgétaires à la
pierre pour toutes ces raisons je
voterai bien évidemment l'amendement de
suppression de l'article 99 dont nous
allons parler et à défaut je proposerai
que le dispositif imaginé par la
commission des finances s'il était
adopté ne soit valable que pour une
durée de 3 ans comme cela était prévu
dans le dispositif initial merci Madame
barizakari merci Madame la présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs messieurs les
ministres chers collègues voilà un
article qui aura fait couler beaucoup
d'encre la rédaction initiale prévue par
le gouvernement a suscité l'inquiétude
et l'incompréhension des organismes de
de bailleurs sociaux il était prévu une
sorte de holdup sur les organismes HLM
pour financer les opérations de l'anrue
en d'autres termes ont demandé aux
classes populaires de financer elles-mêm
les travaux de réhabilitation de leur
logement c'est une formidable
redéfinition de la solidarité nationale
d désormais vous inventez le
cloisonnement solidaire les pauvres
payent pour les pauvres au plus fragile
à ceux qui ont besoin de l'attention de
la nation vous proposer un New Deal
financez vous-même les travaux urgents
dont vous avez besoin cela n'était pas
acceptable mais les députés de la
majorité tout en amendant votre projet
n'ont pas proposé de solutions
alternatives satisfaisantes la
commission des finances de notre
Assemblée a suggéré de ramener la
ponction à 150 millions d'euros par an
nous sommes déjà dans un prélèvement
plus Rais
je vous le concède bien volontiers
l'amendement 227 permettra également de
trouver des ressources pour financer
l'en rue en premier lieu on supprime
l'exonération de cotisation au Fond
national des aides au logement dont
bénéficiaient les employeurs du régime
agricole et l'on prélève une partie des
recettes prévues pour le Grand Paris
j'en déduis que ce mirrifique programme
qu'on nous ventait en début d'année
comme l'alpha et l'oméga de la politique
métropolitaine va progressivement faire
l'objet d'un enterrement de première
classe faute de financi faute de
financement pour une partie de son tracé
voici une nouvelle dont je ne peux que
me réjouir ayant toujours estimé que
cette loi Grand Paris ne répondait pas
de manière adéquate aux enjeux de
développement de la métropole
fran-ilienne je regrette simplement que
le gouvernement se soit montré obtu et
méprisant lors du débat nous aurions pu
avancer de manière plus intéressante
peut-être même aurait-on pu offrir une
réelle perspective à ce projet comme
bien souvent le gouvernement donne dans
l'affichage et au final rien ne reçort
concrètement pour aider nos concitoyens
sur le principe je veux remercier nos
collègues de la commission des finances
pour avoir tenté d'améliorer le texte
sil en avait bien besoin cependant nous
nous opposons à toute ponction sur sur
les organismes HLM le temps n'est pas où
l'on peut fragiliser ces institutions il
me semble de surcroire qu'il faut
analyser plus en profondeur le caractère
péréquateur de cette solution par
ailleurs le ministère reste libre
d'ajuster le taux de contribution des
organismes HLM au vu des derniers
dernier plan proposé par le ministère je
pense qu'il serait déraisonnable de leur
confier le pilotage de ce nouveau
système il est nécessaire de il nous
semble nécessaire de repousser l'article
99 pour imposer à l'état de prendre
réellement ses responsabilités dans la
politique du logement il est
inacceptable qu'il puisse s'affranchir
de son fardeau sans justification aucune
si vous avez besoin d'argent monsieur le
ministre il y a toujours le bouclier
fiscal qui peut venir vous offrir
quelques subsides il suffit simple d'y
mettre un terme d'user de pragmatisme
plus que d'idéologie aux États-Unis nous
venons de le voir les millionnaires et
milliardaair américains viennent
d'adresser une pétition au président
Obama pour être taxé davantage vous
voyez bien que vous fantasmez le désir
des le désir des riches à payer moins
d'impôts en conclusion j'invite mes
collègues à voter pour notre amendement
de suppression merci Maes cher collègu
nous sommes s de trois amendements
identiques faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune l'amendement numéro
107 rectifié Monsieur Jean R qui le
présente merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je serai bref parce que mes deux
collègues Thierry Repentin et bar
Zachari ont dit
l'essentiel nous demandons par cet
amendement la suppression de de
l'article
99 alors évidemment la ponction
envisagée nous l'avons dit n'est plus
aussi douloureuse qu'elle n'était
initialement prévue mais pour autant
nous ne pouvons l'accepter nous ne
pouvons l'accepter tout simplement parce
que cette proposition nous paraît
véritablement inacceptable ce qui est
inacceptable cela a été dit c'est de
faire payer les pauvres pour les plus
pauvres et donc la conséquence de de
cette situation si cette mesure est
adoptée si ce prélèvement est opéré nous
l'avons dit ce sera moins
d'investissement moins de maintenance
pour le parc HLM et on ne peut donc dans
ce contexte de fort besoin soutenir une
telle perspective vous nous dites
monsieur le ministre il faut faire des
économies et nous nous le comprenons
mais à une condition c'est que les
économies envisagées ne soient pas
aveugles qu'ell ne soi pas injustes et
qu'elle n'entve pas non plus le
nécessaire soutien à l'économie et à
l'investissement je ne suis pas
convaincu par les argument que vous avez
donné tout à l'heure et je voudrais y
revenir n'est-il pas contradictoire
d'ouvrir le bénéfice du prêt àau zéro à
des personnes dont les revenus ne le
justifient pas nous savons que nous
aurons des effets d'ben incontestable et
ce sont des pertes de recettes fiscales
assurées pour l'État notamment celles
qui sont dues au au aux deux tranches
supérieures du barem il me semble que là
nous avons des perspectives d'économie
et de recettes qui viendrai utilement
compenser cette perspective de
prélèvement et le 172 rectifié monsieur
Chevenement au nom de Monsieur Collin et
moi-même je présente cet amendement de
suppression de l'article 99 il est clair
que la notion de potentiel
financier qui sert de base au calcul du
prélèvement touchera indifféremment les
organismes ayant une faible activité
d'investissement et ceux qui
investissent massivement notamment dans
les opérations de rénovation urbaine
c'est une mesure injuste absurde
socialement économiquement hein cette
ponction servira aussi bien à apurer les
dettes de l'État au titre du plan de
relance ainsi que du plan national de
rénovation urbaine et non à la
production de logement par conséquent
cette mesure contribuera à pauvrir de
nombreux organismes et pénalisera les
locatair comme l'a rappelé monsieur
mzard tout à l'heure
elle ne peut en aucun cas être qualifiée
d'instrument de
péréquation le 174 madame terade madame
la Présidente même objet que exposé par
mes collègues précédents la volonté de
supprimer cet article qui aura connu un
destin pour le moins mouvementé depuis
sa création rédigé initialement hein
dans une forme particulièrement
inacceptable cette disposition proposait
donc l'application la contribution sur
les revenus locatifs des offices HLM à
hauteur de 2,5 %. celui-ci a été réécrit
pour partie à l'Assemblée nationale pour
remplacer l'assiette de la contribution
sur les revenus locatifs par une
nouvelle taxe sur le potentiel financier
des offices taxe venant se substituer à
celle sur les dos du dormant créé en
2009 pour autant la somme escomptée est
toujours la même et 70 % des offices
seraient encore touchés ces 340 millions
devaient à la fois financer la bosse de
l'enrue mais également palier la
diminution des aides à la pierre ceci
sur une durée de 3 années au Sénat le
rapporteur de la commission des finances
notre collègue d'allier après avoir
proposer sa suppression pure et simple
revient en présentant un réaménagement
de cette taxe c'est-à-dire la diminu
de la recette escomptée pour la ramener
à 150 millions pour notre part nous
allons au bout de la démarche et
proposons la suppression pure et simple
de cet arti clinique nous ne voulons pas
que ce soit uniquement le secteur HLM
qui finance le développement et
l'amélioration du parc de logement
locatifs sociaux celui-ci est déjà
fortement ébranlé par la crise et il n'y
a pas de raison de le mettre encore plus
en difficulté notre argument porte
également sur la forme aucune
négociation n'a été menée entre le
gouvernement et les fice quant à la mise
en œuvre de cette taxation et il y a
d'ailleurs eu une bronca assez
spectaculaire au dernier congrès de
l'ushh à Strasbourg les organismes HLM
ont été mis devant le fait accompli
alors même que au mois de juillet ils
négociaient leur conventionnement avec
l'État ce projet de taxe je l'ai dit a
d'ailleurs été unanimement rejeté par
tous les membres donc de l'USH sur le
fond nous condamnons fermement cette
disposition qui tend à Pier le
désengagement massif de l'État au
financement du logement social le
gouvernement agit comme il l'a fait avec
le 1 % il ne pe plus et il prend en
quelque sorte à Jacques pour donner à
Paul avec des résultats que l'on connaît
pour l'enrue le non financement du
programme national de rénovation Baine 2
la faillite possible du 1 % et une
situation de cessation de paiement pour
l'enrue d'ici le 2 trimestre 2011 la
nouvelle marotte issue de l'adoption de
l'amendement Marignier à l'article 34 et
maintenant de donner à l'enrue les
recettes qui auraient dû financer la
Société du Grand Paris
vraiment on pense que vous ne savez plus
quoi inventer pour palier au
désengagement de l'État aussi nous
proposons nous une solution très simple
que l'État prenne ses responsabilités en
terme de politique de la ville sans
faire appel systématique à des
intervenants extérieurs et qu'il propose
l'adoption d'une loi de finances qui
réponde au défi de la crise du logement
c'est pour toutes ces raisons madame la
Présidente que nous demandons la
suppression de cette
article ma chè collègue maintenant
l'avis de la commission
bien évidemment madame la Présidente la
commission des finances demande à nos
collègues de se rallier à l'amendement
de la commission et non pas de supprimer
purement et simplement cet article et je
rappellerai simplement que il n'est pas
anormal que nous mettions en place un
vrai un vrai mécanisme de péréquation
entre bailleurs sociaux d'ailleurs il me
semble pas avoir entendu l'ensemble des
bailleurs prendre une position contraire
non il faut mettre en place un véritable
mécanisme de péréquation c'est ce que
nous allons tenter de vous proposer
monsieur braille
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre et mes chers collègues bon je
regrette un petit peu effectivement ce
qui se passe actuellement tout
simplement c'est qu'on je veux dire
regarde le logement d'une façon
excessivement parcellaire et pas dans sa
façon globale bon je rappellerai tout
simplement à tous mes collègues ici
présents qu'il y a deux fois plus de
personnes pauvres c'est-à-dire qu'ils
sont en dessous de 30 % du plafond HLM
dans le logement privé que dans le
logement social et tout le monde le sait
je veux dire nous avons 1 million de
propriétaires occupant pauvres et cetera
et 1 million de personnes que pauvres
qui sont dans le logement locatif social
donc deux fois plus de personnes pauvre
que dans logement social et
personnellement j'aurais euh je veux
dire il faudrait quand même une bonne
fois pour toutes arrêter de considérer
l'État à la lueur exclusivement des
aides des aides directes à la pierre et
regarder un petit peu ce qu'il y met et
donc je le dis pour avoir été rapporteur
de la loi molle avoir voulu instiller un
un un commencement de P équation au
niveau des bailleurs sociaux et mêre
aperçu à ma grande je veux dire surprise
à quel point les organismes sociaux
avaient été capable de s'organiser pour
ne payer à eux tous que 7000 € je veux
dire au niveau de cette pééquation donc
monsieur le ministre moi j'en appelle je
veux dire à votre à votre attention sur
le fait que je considère le mot est un
petit peu fort mais qu'il y a une vraie
réaction corporatiste des organismes HLM
qui ont pour be beaucoup d'entre eux
oubli la vocation sociale qui était là
l'heure et que il serait grand temps je
veux dire monsieur le Président
effectivement de l'US que vous rappeliez
vos mandants je veux dire à leur
vocation sociale qu'ils ont quelquefois
oublié donc il faut enfin puisque je
voterai naturellement l'amendement de la
commission en sachant que ni la
proposition qui nous était faite sur les
340 millions ni la proposition vous m'en
excuserz monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission des finances que vous nous
proposez n'est parfaite elle est loin
d'être parfaite fait il serait bon de
mettre en place une véritable
péréquation puisque nous voyons la
richesse des des bailleurs sociaux vient
quand même essentiellement de ce que
leur apporte l'État à travers la
diminution de TVA à travers les aides à
la pierre et à travers les aides à la
personne n'oubliez pas que 34 % des
loyers je veux dire des organisteslm
sont payés par les aides à la pierre et
que si les organistlm ont une trésorerie
tel qu'ils l'ont et des fonds comme ils
les ont ils le doivent en grande partie
à l'état et que de ce côté-là et donc au
contribu français et que de ce côté-là
ils doivent avoir et enfin je veux dire
mettre leur fond à la disposition je
veux dire des plus modeste d'entre eux
c'est-à-dire je veux dire appliquer la
vocation sociale qui devrait être laide
donc monsieur le ministre il est grand
temps en tout cas pour les années qui
viennent de mettre en place une
véritable péréquation où les organismes
qui NT déjà je veux dire un patrioine
complètement amorti et qui sur lequel il
n'y a pas de besoin nouveaux puisqu'ils
sont dans les zones non end ou alors
ceux qui au contraire jouent les do du
dormant c'est-à-dire qu' ne construisent
pas là où il devrait construire et ben
que ceci soit ponctionné pour aller vers
ceux effectivement qui construisent et
là monsieur le Président de l'USH je
suis totalement opposé à ce que vous
dites parce que au contraire récupérer
ces fonds d'organismes qui ne
construisent pas pour les ramener je
veux dire des organismes qui
construisent ce sera effectivement
augmenter le nombre de construction de
logement et non pas la diminuer comme de
nous le faire croire le président de
l'usage donc je le dis je veux dire très
sincèrement il est grand temps que les
bailleurs sociaux retrouvent leur
vocation sociale qu'ils ont abandu pour
un certain nombre d'entre eux depuis
fort longtemps monsieur
Repentin présidente on va prendre le
temps qu'il faut sur cette question car
on peut affirmer avec force des ponsifs
ça reste des ponsifs je viens d'en
entendre plusieurs et je veux répondre
précisément notamment à à celui qui
interpelle un parlementaire non pas dans
ses responsabilités de parlementaires
mais dans ses responsabilité
professionnelle de représentant
effectivement d'une profession moi je
souhaite vous dire plusieurs choses
premièrement le monde HLM est loin
d'avoir oublié sa vocation sociale mes
chers collègues au cours des deux
dernières années
tous les nouveaux entrants dans le parc
achelem étaient plus pauvres que ceux
qui en sont partis 70 % des nouveaux
entrants sont sous plafond plai monsieur
le Président de
l'ANA première chose deuxième chose sur
l'année 2009 comptenu de la crise
économique qui a touché de plein fois
notre pays et au premier rang desquels
les locataires du monde HLM nous avons
eu à gérer une augmentation de 30 % des
impayés de loyers 30 % des impayés de
loyer de plus de 3 mois dans le monde
HLM et une augmentation de 50 % des
procédures de surendettement toujours
chez le locataire du monde HLM alors on
peut pour soutenir le gouvernement
affirmer ici des contrevérités il
n'empêche ça reste des contrevérités et
j'aurais souhaité que ce débat continue
comme il s'était engagé sereinement sans
entendre effectivement des contrevérité
et moi je vais vous dire Monsieur le
Président de
l'ANA que vous auriez pu citer d'autres
mesures d'accompagnement qui coûtent à
l'état puisque vous avez cité par
exemple la TVA mais ce la TVA 55 elle
existe depuis bien longtemps plusieurs
gouvernements successifs l'ont maintenu
vous auriez pu citer également le coût
de l'exonération de taxes sur le foncier
bâti dont bénéficient les organismes de
logement social qui perdure depuis
plusieurs gouvernements vous auriez pu
citer aussi le coût pour la nation des
prêts bonifiés de lacais et dépôts et
consignation que nous essayons
d'ailleurs de sauver actuellement et
vous le savez monsieur le ministre parce
qu'il y a danger sur l'avenir de la
Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation à
travers la centralisation qui est remise
en cause tout ça sont des constantes le
seul levier le seul levier qui fait la
différence monsieur le Président c'est
celui des aides à la pierre car toute
chose égale par ailleurs TVA 55
exonération TFPB je viens d'en parler
près de la Cais dépôt et consignation
c'est la ligne fongible qui
effectivement apporte le montant de la
subvention aux constructions de
logements sociaux et force de constater
force de constater que depuis le début
des années 2000 la subvention unitaire
apportée à chaque logement social
construit dans notre pays est en
diminution en 10ant elle est passée de
7000 € à l'an prochain une moyenne de
800 € c'est un constat point barre ce
qui veut dire que au cours des 10
dernières années les collectivités
locales oui ce sont substituer avec les
fonds propres des organismes HLM pour
construire plus de logements dans notre
pays et on doit tous s'en réjouir mais
il faut arrêter de dire que d'un côté il
y a les bons et de l'autre côté il y a
les mauvais monsieur le Président de
l'ANA voilà moi je réaffirme haut eff
fort ici que le monde HLM n'a jamais
jamais oublié sa vocation sociale et je
suis assez fier de le dire devant la
représentation nationale monsieur le
ministre
monsieur madame la la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
quelques éléments de réponse si vous le
voulez bien concernant différentes
interventions d' là quelques
instants je voudrais rappeler deux trois
petites choses à certain j'ai bien
entendu que tout ce qui était bien
c'était les collectivités locales et le
monde HLM et tout ce qui était pas bien
c'était l'état ça je crois que ce résume
là on l'aura tous compris depuis
quelques quelques minutes jerais quand
même vous rappeler qu'on on peut oublier
en permanence dans les discours des uns
et des autres les dépenses fiscales de
l'État certes ces dépenses fiscales
existe depuis longtemps certes elles
sont justifiées ça n'interdit en rien de
rappeler que l'État dépense en dehors
des laaperre 4 milliards de dépenses
fiscales au bénéfice du monde HLM plus 5
milliards d'aide personnell au logement
ça fait 9 milliards de dépenses de
l'État alors j'entends bien que la seule
chose qui intéresse les organisme et si
je si j'entends bien la seule chose qui
intéresse l'opposition c'est de ne
parler que de 500 millions mais soit
vous nous dites que les 9 milliards ne
servent à
rien soit vous nous dites que ça sert à
rien et à ce moment-là ben on en
discutera les uns les autres mais il y a
un moment je voudrais juste qu'on ait un
peu dans ces discours de sincérité et de
vérité pour reprendre vos propos non
l'investissement de l'État ne se limite
pas aux aide à la pierre il y a 9
milliards à côté et j'aimerais de temps
en temps qu'on n'oublie pas ces 9
milliards d'euros si vous le voulez bien
premier point deuxème point oui il y a
au sein du monde HLM des bailleurs
sociaux qui ont moins besoin de
construire il ne s'agit pas de les
pointer du doigt en disant qu'il tésoris
il s'agit simplement de se dire que sur
certains territoires il y a moins besoin
de construire que sur certains
territoires il y a un patrimoine amorti
qui donc gage des richesses il me semble
si mes souvenirs sont bons que c'est un
gouvernement que vous souteniez qui a
imaginé le principe de péréquation entre
les collectivités locales parce que ce
gouvernement considérait qu'il y avait
des collectivités locales plus riches
que d'autres et donc on a inventé la
péréquation entre les collectivités
locales ce que nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui c'est d'inventer la
péréquation entre des bailleurs sociaux
qui dégagent des richesses parce qu'ils
ont moins besoin de produire et d'autres
AES bailleurs sociaux qui eux au
contraire ont besoin de financement
nouveau pour pouvoir construire c'est ça
la réalité ce que nous vous proposons
enfin concernant la préconisation qui
est faite par les uns et les autres de
dire prenons au prê à tau zéro pour
donner au HLM je reprendrai ce que vient
de dire Dominique braay la politique du
logement c'est un ensemble le parcours
locatif que vous ventez le parcours
résidentiel pardon que vous ventez les
uns et les autres dans vos discours il
faut en tirer des conséquences concrètes
cons d'opposer l'accession à la
propriété au logement social mais c'est
ce que vous faites me semble-t-il quand
vous dites je prends 400 millions
d'euros à l'accession à la propriété
pour le mettre au HLM vous prenez à
l'accession à la propriété pour donner
au HLM moi je considère qu'une politique
du logement doit so appuyer sur trois
piliers le pilier du logement social qui
est indispensable le pilier de
l'investis locatif qui est indispensable
le pilier de l'accession à la propriété
qui est indispensable enfin dernier
point je répète une chose concernant le
prêt àau zéro que j'ai évoqué tout à
tout à l'heure si vous
considérez que pour un célibataire en
zone C 1554 € précis de revenus c'est
trop riche pour être aidé nous n'avons
pas la même conception de la richesse je
sais bien que vous avez cité en certain
temps quelques chiffres en la matière
nous n'avons probablement pas la même
constitution de la richesse moi je
considère qu'Aer quelqu'un qui gagne
1554 € en zone C pour devenir
propriétaire ce n'est pas donner de
l'argent à un riche je considère que
c'est donné de l'argent à quelqu'un qui
en a besoin pour devenir propriétaire
voilà peut-être ce qui nous différencie
en la matière enfin un dernier point si
vous le voulez bien qui m'a sincèrement
frappé dans le mauvais sens du terme
c'est normal qu'une institution comme
les bailleurs soci etess évidemment de
convaincre les uns et les autres de la
véracité de ses propos c'est logique
mais permettez-moi de vous dire une
chose que des bailleurs sociaux se
payent des pages de pub dans des
journaux en allignant des contevérités
des mensonges des mensonges dans des
pages de pub payé sur le dos des
locatair je vous le dis entre nous ça me
paraît aller beaucoup trop loin surtout
quand tout ce qui est indiqué dans la
page de pub en question est totalement
inexact je vous réaffirme les choses
suivantes non l'État ne se désengage pas
du logement
social bien monsieur le président de la
commission des
finances juste un mot pour vous dire
qu'il nous reste 25 minutes et 12
amendements à
examiner bien alors je reviens sur ces
trois amendements faisant le l'objet
d'une discussion commune la Commission a
la Commission a prononcé un avis
défavorable le gouvernement
également je mets donc au voix ces
amendements ceux qui sont favorables à
leur adoption alors adoption lèverons la
main ceux qui sont contre ils ne sont
pas
adopté un amendement et 12
sous-amendements toujours à l'article 99
l'amendement 27 monsieur
Dallier merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers voilà
donc la réécriture de l'article 99
dernier étage de la fusée que la
commission des finances vous
soumet alors je je vais plutôt que de
détailler le contenu de de de cet
amendement vous présenter les grandes
lignes pour essayer de de permettre à
chacun de s'exprimer puisqu'il y a
beaucoup de sous-amendements première
chose que je souhaiterais dire nous
avons essayé de garantir que les 150
millions que nous sont récupéré si je
puis dire au terme de la péréquation
entre organisme soit garanti première
caractéristique de ce dispositif dans
celui qui était sorti de l'Assemblée
nationale on pouvait effectivement
douter que le produit attendu soit là au
bout du compte donc nous avons souhaité
effectivement trouver une solution qui
permette de nous assurer que les 150
millions attendus seront bien nos
rendez-vous ce qui suppose effectivement
que les bailleurs sociaux jouent le jeu
et en quelque sorte cet amendement
permet de les responsabiliser puisque si
certains essayaient de passer au travers
du dispositif en remboursant des
emprunts comme ça a été expliqué puisque
ça a été fait et bien effectivement les
150 millions nous serions en capacité de
les récupérer et j'allais dire ce sont
les autres qui eux auraient joué le jeu
qui effectivement contribueront plus
donc il faut être clair ce dispositif
permet également outre d'avoir la
certitude du montant de responsabiliser
l'ensemble des bailleurs sociaux et en
cela il nous semble intéressant seconde
caractéristique de cet amendement les
150 millions iront donc exclusivement
aux aides à la pierre et c'était bien
une des principales critiques formulées
il n'est plus ici question de financer
l'en rue puisque nous avons trouvé la
solution par ailleurs donc sur ces 150
millions 80 millions remonteront dans le
budget de l'État au travers d'un fond de
concours ce qui veut dire que 70
millions resteront dans la S de LS et
contribueront également au financement
du logement social donc on est bien là
effectivement dans un mécanisme de
péréquation qui contribuera au
développement de l'offre de logement
voilà donc pour la séance d'hier soir
les sénateurs reprendront donc l'examen
des crédits de la mission logement
samedi ils reprendront à l'article 99
prochain rendez-vous de l'actualité
parlementaire 16h30 pour toujours le
budget 2011 et cette fois-ci les
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales et bien sûr vous pouvez
retrouver la séance en VoD sur notre
site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires certains politiques
s'expriment beaucoup par geste mais que